traffic
Leute soll ich euch mal was erzählen ich habe versucht auf YouTube Channel Membership
einzuschalten oder wie das auch immer genau heißt YouTube Subscriptions membership heißt
das habe ich versucht einzuschalten ich habe mir gedacht ich mache es einfach total simpel
ich mache einen Basic Tier 2.99 für Badges und Emotes und ein ich bin super reich für 8.99
wo es nichts mehr gibt außer wenn man mehr Geld ausgeben will und das dumme ist YouTube möchte
dass man Zusatz Perks anbietet neben Badges und Emotes was soll man denn da anbieten ist total
schwach sind Badges und Emotes 2.99 das reicht Zusatz Zusatz Perks Zusatz Perks kann ich ja
irgendwas reinschreiben aber warum muss man überhaupt irgendwas reinschreiben also ist
wirklich komisch dieses System kein Wunder dass es kaum jemand macht auf YouTube OnlyFans
PewDiePie hat OnlyFans drinstehen frag mich was man dann da kriegt es muss
irgendein G-Bait sein auf jeden Fall
leider gibt es nichts in der Richtung dafür dafür nimmt sich YouTube weniger Cut oder Share
wie man das nennen mag vom Geld was du bei YouTube Subs ausgibst also bei Twitch ist es ja in der
Regel 50 50 und bei YouTube ist es 30 70 standardmäßig wenn man wenn man nichts
spezielles mit denen aus handelt was du wahrscheinlich erst ab 50 Millionen Abos
oder so ganz keine Ahnung was ich mache ich sitze gerade vor meinem Rechner und gucke
auf den Twitch Chat das wäre aber auf jeden Fall gut ja ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß bei
YouTube und auch bei Twitch musst du schon eine gewisse Größe haben denke ich mal
würde mich ja mal interessieren was da was wirklich große da kriegen
Leute ich habe immer noch Halsweh immer noch Husten und ich habe keinen Corona Test da
ich kann nicht mal ich kann nicht mal Corona Test machen das Zeug ist übrigens mega teuer
geworden ich wollte letztens mal weil ich habe mir überlegt ob ich bei Amazon mir so
einen 10er Pack kaufe Corona Test und da kosten 20 Stück jetzt 50 Euro oder so was
nochmal allein schon 5 Stück kosten 20 Euro die haben mal 2 Euro das Stück gekostet 7
Stück 42 Euro null 25 118 Euro kann man sich irgendwo noch kostenlos testen lassen ja stimmt
stimmt ich kriege die auf der Arbeit auch umsonst aber ich habe Urlaub bis Januar ich habe
keinen Bock nach Frankfurt zu fahren
was ist denn ein Burger Test ja wir haben ja so ein Testzentrum hier nicht weit weg
da lasse ich mich mal Corona kriegt man da einfach einen Test in die Hand gedrückt darf
das selbst machen oder schieben die einem dann so ein Ding in die Nase oder darf man
sich das ausdenken ich will keinen Zertifikat ich will einfach so einen schnellen Test haben
so ein Ding was in 5 Minuten durch ist
also ich habe bei uns noch nie einen kostenlosen PCR Selbsttest Kit gesehen ne die Dinger sind
mittlerweile relativ teuer die waren mal bei 2 Euro mittlerweile bezahlste dreifache für
ich könnte mir einfach bei Amazon welche bestellen aber guck mal hier 5 pack 20 Euro
wobei das geht 20 Euro durch 5 ups wenn man jetzt so richtig schreiben könnte durch 5
Euro das Stück naja Hot Gen Corona Rapid Test wie funzen die aha in die Nase schiebe drehen
und dann 15 der bis 17 der bis dahin ist Corona schon wieder rum sollte ich sagen
das heißt nicht jeb cock es heißt jeb Corona im zweifelsfall mit Taschenrechte
auf keine Tests von Boson warum weil muss man sich zu sehr in die Nase rammen oder was
ich habe es seit komplett Corona angefangen hat ich habe bisher nur 2 Corona Tests gemacht
und sie haben ich selbst gemacht nämlich Naso Check vom Lidl
kriegste halt gerade keinen angeblich verfügbar ich muss ich muss mal wirklich morgen ist
am Montag ich hole mir mal ein Lidl Naso Check und dann wird gebohrt in die Nase
ja ich habe auch nur selbst Tests gemacht bisher was bedeutet der Zug das ist dass
du ein Current Hype Train Conductor bist ist jetzt alles klar das weiß man Bescheid oder
ich finde jetzt ist obvios was Sache ist ja ich sagte es ist schwierig da was zu bekommen
das ist ein Kürbis ich habe einen Booster Termin für Februar und das letzte mal geimpft
wurde ich irgendwann bis ich 20. August oder so
ja habe ich habe ich zum größten Teil ich brauche aber noch was ich brauche für meine
Mutter ein iPhone Case ich habe mal bei denen eins bestellt aber das war ganz schön teuer
ich glaube das ist immer noch ganz schön teuer
ich brauche nämlich ein iPhone 11 Silikon Case so was da wobei eigentlich geht es vom
Preis doch so was da brauche ich noch aber die sind ja immer relativ schnell
also meinst du das wenn man geimpft ist dass die selbst Tests dann nichts erkennen obwohl
man was hat oder dass die eher anschlagen obwohl man nichts hat
das wäre jetzt die Frage es kann richtig Hustchamp machen aber zum Glück habe ich mal Mute Button
Hustchamp das wäre doch mal was für irgendeine Corona App die ordentlich funktioniert Hustchamp.org
also meinst du es besser ich gehe in irgendein Impfzentrum und lasse mir so Dinge in die
Nase stecke haben die im Impfzentrum auch was wo sie einem was in den Hals stecken
Hals stecken ist mir lieber anstatt Nase stecken
kann man sich doch bestimmt aussuchen ich war noch nie in einem Impfzentrum ich habe
keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert
Lolli Tests aber das brauche ich jawoll das gibt es sinnbar gibt es das und wir reden
hier nicht von sondern von Lutschern Corona Lolli Tests sowas brauche ich das ist genau
das Richtige für mich Alter wird ja immer teurer wird gelutscht
woran wird da ah hier was ist besser das zum Lutschen oder das zum in die Nase stecke
Nase ist genauer Corona Test Test alles klar zeig mal her Test Station Volltext Suche
Guck mal Hanau Hanau Suchen am Markt in Hanau Spuck Test Spuck Spuck Test ist gut da muss
man nichts machen außer Spucken Pock ein Pock Gentest
Ach nee ein Pock kein Pock was haben wir sonst noch hier am Markt ist gut da weiß ich wo
das ist das ist mitten in Hanau weiß ich nicht wo das ist doch das weiß ich wo das
ist Testzentrum Hanau at GMX wirkt ja äußerst vertrauenswürdig mit der GMX Adresse
ja mal schauen mal schauen
ich glaube habe ich schon mal gesehen auf Twitch ja dass die haben früher Starcraft
gemacht wenn die das sind dann habe ich da früher mal ab und zu geguckt ja bebrauche
sie das denn weil ich am husten bin schon seit ein paar Tagen
Hust Hustchamp mache ich seit ein paar Tagen habe ich mir gedacht muss man jetzt mal es
gibt ja keine anderen Krankheiten außer Corona mehr also muss es ja Corona sein wenn ich
wusste
True ja sag ich doch so also YouTube was empfiehlt zu uns denn heute es gibt eine richtig
gutes Video bei dabei ich weiß ja ob wir das gucken das sind 31 minuten Battlefield
2042 what the fuck happened das ist der Ober ober leaker von twitter der auch zu Battlefield
schon sehr viel geleakt hat
eher schlupflung kein husten tja ganz ehrlich da verlasse ich mich jetzt nicht drauf
mir tut sowohl der Hals ein bisschen weh auch dass ich husten muss und vom ganzen husten
merke ich jetzt oben schon ein bisschen ich glaube nicht dass das Lunge ist aber so ein
bisschen weiter weiter runter weil ich die ganze Zeit Huststalls gemacht habe
ja also der Typ ist richtig Pog der ist ja die ganze Zeit am Liken und er hat ein richtig
gutes Video gemacht zur so wie heißt das auf Deutsch Timeline Zeitstrahl wie nennt
man Timeline auf deutsch Zeitleiste alles klar ok eine Zeitleiste vom Battlefield 2042
Entwicklung und was alles in die Hose gegangen ist finde da sind ein paar interessante Sachen
dabei
ich weiß halt nicht ob wir eine halbe Stunde gucken wollen wir lassen uns erstmal wir lassen
uns erstmal von level capji baiten und dann gucken wir mal was was es sonst noch gibt
ja ganz ehrlich am liebsten würde ich einen Schnelltest selbst machen da müsste man aber
erstmal im Lidl ein kriegen da weiß ich gehe einfach morgen früh in Lidl oder in Aldi oder
in Edeka oder in Rossmann es gibt ja genug Läden in bei uns in der Ecke und holen wir
irgend so einen komischen Corona Test und dann wird erstmal gelutscht oder in die Nase geschoben
oder was auch immer 14€ ist ja ein Schnapper im Lidl kostet es 2,99€ was gucken wir uns
den jetzt an
ich hab keinen Bock auf Impfzentrum wie ist denn das im Impfzentrum kriegt man bei den
Tests noch das Ding komplett in die Nase gerammt oder nur im vorderen Nasenbereich wie ist
das weil komplett in die Nase gerammt hab ich keinen Bock drauf ja das hilft mir jetzt
nicht für die Aussage ne ne ich mach das selbst ich lass die nicht an meine Nase ran
ein floated game naja so gucken wir uns mal ein paar Witz an was haben wir denn hier schönes
zu bieten dann werden wir uns erstmal ne Runde von LevelCapture Baiten komm mal her LevelCapture
Bait geht immer Can Battlefield Future Escape also der hat ja auch immer Titel und wetten
das sagt nix sinnvolles wetten das sagt jetzt sowas irgendwie so die übliche Geschichte
Battlefield hatte einen schweren Start und DICE gelobt Besserung in Zukunft nächstes
Thema irgendwie sowas es wird sowas komplett Battlefield was up to a rough start oder irgendwie
sowas so 0815 Ding wird er jetzt sagen und dann nächstes Thema Hauptsache hat ganz
ein Battlefield im Titel steht ok gucken wir mal
ok lull moment da müssen wir das eigentlich gar nicht gucken wenn das vom achten ist vom
achten juckt doch keinen mehr who cares vom achten alter das Update ist ja schon raus
und das war weder big noch hat es großartig was gebracht Doppel G Bait ja hat eigentlich
irgendjemand der vielleicht sogar damals die allerersten Matrix Filme oder den allerersten
Matrix Film im Kino gesehen hat oder so mal diesen Matrix Hype damals mitgekriegt hat
hat irgendjemand wirklich Hoffnung da drin dass der Matrix 4 oder was es ist irgendwas
taugt also ich nicht unabhängig davon ob die sich Mühe geben oder nichts oder wie auch
immer aber der zweite und dritte Teil war schon nicht gut und der erste ist einfach
unangefochten für mich eines der besten Filme die es gibt dass der vierte Teil irgendwas
taugt glaube ich ist fast ausgeschlossen ich lasse mich ja gerne eines anderen belehren
aber ich werde definitiv mich dafür nicht ins Kino hangen ich gucke mir das online
irgendwo an sobald es dann raus ist und sag dann danach wieder jawoll ich wusste es das
wird nichts so ok wir lassen uns hier nicht G Baiten wir lassen uns hier nicht G Baiten
gibt es nichts zu gucken so schauen wir zén kommenNä das ist metz never engineerin your
called lab oder ich find das immer gut da kann ich mich immer darüber auslassen was
was eigentlich abgeht mit alter das ist auch wieder so eindeutig imõl übertreibt das
Gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Aber wenigstens sagt er Overengineering.
Okay, das ist, das ist, ist es Dell oder ist es HP, Leute?
Das kann beides sein.
Ich würde, ich würde sagen, es ist, es ist HP von den, von dem, von der Farbe und von
dem Aufbau her.
Was meint ihr?
Was hat, was hat er denn hier neben Raspberry Pi im Bilderrahmen oder sowas?
Okay, das von der Farbe her könnte das durch und von dem Ding könnte das durch, Cisco
Switcher sein oder Cisco, wie manche Leute sagen.
Aber Cisco habe ich übrigens noch nie gehört.
Also Cisco kenne ich und Cisco, aber das anders hat es noch keiner ausgesprochen.
Was ist Dell?
Okay, ja, auf.
Also im Vergleich zu dem anderen Dude ist das er hier kaum noch Overengineert.
Ich meine, guck dir mal da, das ist immerhin nur, nur in Anführungszeichen.
Zwei mal 2 HE Storage Kisten, Festplatten dazu, zwei Switcher und eine NAS, das ist doch
eigentlich im Vergleich zu dem, was wir da schon auf YouTube gesehen haben, eigentlich
noch voll im Rahmen.
Cisco, das habe ich auch noch nicht gehört.
Ja, hieß los.
Er hat da bestimmt auch nur Linux ISUS, die sich über Torrent gezogen hat, auf den Festplatten
drauf.
Gleich mal kurz checken, ob die Lautstärke in Ordnung ist.
So, obviously in this series, I'm going to be rebuilding my home lab and hopefully in
the process I get to share some geeky and helpful stuff with you guys.
I won't be doing any tech demos in this video, but I do want to show you what I've been getting
up to and what I plan on getting.
Jawoll.
Jet startet.
Deswegen hat man sowas normalerweise auch nicht im Büro stehen.
Warum benutzt jeder eigentlich diese Jahresansagen, die sehe ich in jedem zweiten Video.
So, as you can hear, after the server posts and settles down, the volume does come down
quite substantially, but it's still wildly unacceptable to deal with.
Der Witz ist, ich muss mal kurz zurückgehen hier, mit den Lüftern, das ist so, das ist
bei den meisten Servern so, das geht volle Pulle an und dann, deshalb die haben ja Sensoren
drauf und alles, dann gehen die Lüfter ein bisschen runter, aber wisst ihr was ihr machen
müsst, damit jeder Server erst mal auf volle Pulle, volle Pulle Lüfter schaltet?
Ihr müsst einfach eines der beiden oder vier Netzteile rausziehen und die meisten Systeme
schalten instant auf volle Lüfterstärke, sobald ein Netzteil kaputt ist, was komisch
ist, weil eigentlich fragt man sich, warum das dann eigentlich noch fadende Meer belastet,
aber keine Ahnung.
Das erste, sobald ihr das Netzteil rauszieht, ist wirklich von normal zu, wie willst du
ausrasten?
So, as you can hear, after the server posts and settles down, the volume does come down
quite substantially, but it's still wildly unacceptable to deal with.
Zu laut fürs Büro.
Okay, wo sehen wir denn hier was?
Hier, hier wird gebaut.
To be somewhat portable in case I ever needed to move.
Wenigstens hat er mal ein schönes, ist das ein IKEA Rack oder ist das ein richtig, ich
glaube das ist ein richtig normales Rack, doch nice.
Wenigstens war schön ins Server in der Garage zusammengeschraubt.
Before I get into what I have planned for all of this stuff, here's a little overview of
what the hardware is and what it's capable of.
Was gibt's?
So if you've seen some of my previous videos, some of this may look a little bit familiar,
so over here I've got this TP-Link switch and these L3020M micro-
Ich glaube so billigen TP-Link-Switch hatte jeder schon mal.
Alter, warum haben die alle daheim ein Kubernetes-Cluster, was machen die denn da für super high-availability-shit
daheim?
Ich meine zum Lernen und zum Angucken mag das ja alles ganz cool sein, aber die betreiben
das ja ernsthaft.
Was machen die denn da alle?
Wie viel, das ist ja nix, 250G, das ist ja nix, 500G, das ist ja nix, 500G, das ist
ja nix, die hat er bestimmt bei eBay billig gekriegt, 500G, Alter, der Stromverbrauch
für quasi keine Leistung und keinen Speicherplatz, 500G in 2021, mann, was ist da mit den Leuten
los?
Okay, das sind Ami Strompreise wahrscheinlich.
Neue Cisco 2960G-Switches, ich dachte ich könnte zumindest meine Cisco-Networking-Skills
ausprobieren und dann die meisten-
Netta-Lists sind auch noch die teuren.
Das sind die zwei Super-Micro-Servers, das hat alles von eBay.
Die Super-Micro-Servers sehen vielleicht aus wie die zwei Us-Servers, aber die sind
von den fast-
Das sind Super-Micro-Dinger, von der Farbe sehen die aus wie HP.
Wait a minute, das ist irgendwie so ein Playcenter für Arme, oder?
Was ist das für Hexenwerk?
Was ist das?
Okay, das ist doch mehr over-ingeniert, als ich am Anfang angenommen habe.
Ja, der sagt es wenigstens, die meisten Leute machen das einfach just for fun und nicht,
weil sie es wirklich brauchen.
Das sehe ich nämlich auch so.
Alternativ könnte man das einfach auch zum Beispiel in der Hetzner-Cloud machen, Ausrufezeichen
Hetzner im Chat, wer sich einen 21-Euro-Startgutschein sichern will, weil anstatt so was lokal zu
lernen, sich das lokal hinzustellen, ist glaube ich die deutlich bessere Variante, zu
irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter zu gehen und dort sich was zu hosten, weil, wozu soll ich das
lokal haben, wenn ich es einfach nur zum Ausprobieren haben will?
Was?
Moment, jetzt komme ich nicht mehr mit, das ist mir jetzt zu weit, zu weit, was?
Okay.
Ja, da habe ich auch schon immer dran gedacht, also mein Rack, das hat schon viel Ähnlichkeit
zu so einer Kuh.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Oh, jetzt kommt die Big Brain Cloud Architektur, also ist das das GitLab Logo, Leute könnte
das das GitLab Logo sein, das kann auch sein, dass ich es durcheinander bringe.
Wenn er das machen will, da braucht er überhaupt nichts dazu daheim zu haben, das kann man
wunderbar in irgendeiner Cloud-Umgebung testen und wenn man es ganz abgedreht haben möchte,
man kann das sogar in der Cloud-Umgebung testen, wo man nur selbst Zugriff drauf hat, also
es ist überhaupt nicht notwendig zum Üben und zum Basteln in der Richtung wirklich lokal
so fette Hardware hinzustellen, es sei denn, man wohnt in Krakow, Land und Strom ist billig
und eBay-Hardware ist billig, da kann man das sicherlich machen.
Was ist mit der Musik im Hintergrund eigentlich los, die Musik, weißt du was, ja komm, ich
hab gedacht man sieht ja so ein bisschen mehr, Ubuntu, was, ok, also, ja, was Ubuntu und was
installiert da, Mass, ach ist das dieses Ubuntu, dieses Ubuntu Installations-Scripting-Ding
oder was, was ist Mass, Moment, vielleicht, Mass, was ist Mass, hat irgendjemand einen
Plan, was da was, ok, Mass ist was mit Kubernetes, Mass, Ubuntu, ich suche da jetzt mal, Mass,
Ubuntu, ach Mass, Metal Assets Service, was, Alter, gibt es mittlerweile schon irgendwas,
was nicht Assets Service ist, was zum Teufel soll ein Metal Assets Service sein, is das
so eine Art Aufbau, so eine Art PXE Server oder sowas, wo du von Bootes und dann Ubuntu
installierst, was einfach nur cool klingt, Metal Assets Service, ok, ich check nicht,
was es sein soll, Erklärung, ja erklärt es mir mal, ja, Mass, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was es sein soll, how it works, install, tour, KVM Micro Clouds, was wollt ihr denn überhaupt
von mir, was soll, was ist das denn überhaupt, Self Service Remote Installation of Windows,
Unreal Servers turns your data center into bare Metal Clouds, ich hab keine Ahnung, was
das sein soll, ich check es wirklich nicht, ist das ein PXE Server, wo man, wo man einfach
easy Zeug drüber installieren kann oder was ist das, also wenn die Beschreibung schon
so wir ist, dann braucht man es wahrscheinlich in der Regel auch nicht, your next track is
a bare Metal Cloud, was wollt ihr von mir, ich lecke richtig Critical Information, ich
fürchte nur, dass irgendwie die Leute da selbst Critical Information lecken, weil ich hab
keine Ahnung, Key Features, Automation, Storage Layout, wenn du ganz viele virtuelle Maschinen
haben willst, dann nehme ich eine Kiste und installiere mir entweder ein Ubuntu Server
drauf, mach KVM oder besser mach ich ein ESX drauf, hört sich nach PXE an, ja sowas würde
ich, sowas würde ich auch vermuten, Juju, achja Juju ist irgendein Ubuntu Deployment
Zeug, Netboot using PXE, das ist glaube ich eine Installation, um ESX und sowas einfacher
installieren zu können, was auch immer, ok wir gucken jetzt mal in das Video weiter,
ach stimmt, das können wir uns ja gleich mal angucken, das sind, die Witcher Season ist
doch jetzt, kommt doch raus, stimmt hab ich ganz vergessen, nachdem ich die erste Witcher
Season ganz ok fand, jetzt nichts weltbewegendes, gucken was die mit der zweiten machen, jetzt
haben sie auf jeden Fall ein bisschen mehr Budget und die Special Effects kann man auch
Special Effects nennen, ok weiter, was will er damit machen, ok, also M.A.S. ist wirklich
so eine PXE Server, fertig aus ok, also M.A.S. ist wirklich so eine PXE Server, fertig aus
Ok.
Weißt du was lustig ist, wieso man hier sieht dass es für das HomeLab vollkommenunn geeignet
ist, er hat jetzt schon ein ultra komplexes Setup, damit das überhaupt funktioniert und
hat noch nicht eine Sache darauf laufen. Er hat bisher nur Management für das Management,
um das Management zu managen. Er hat nicht einen Service daheim laufen bisher und trotzdem
schon ziemlich komplexes Setup. Also daran sieht man, dass es für heim Setup, wenn man
einfach nur es benutzen will, total overkill, aber es sagt ja selbst, Overengineering und
zum Lernen, das ist natürlich was anderes.
Was? Was zum Teufel ist Juju?
Ist das was mit dem Zug zu tun, der hupt oder?
Ich glaube, Juju ist irgendein Ubuntu Zeug.
Was? Okay, jetzt will er es wissen, jetzt will er es wissen.
Aha.
Ah, alles klar, alles klar. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der will, aber okay.
Aha, alles klar, alles klar.
Natürlich, natürlich, obviously, obviously. Und wisst ihr, was jetzt noch besseres Beispiel
ist dafür, dass es sich für daheim nicht eignet? Er hat das hier alles gebaut ohne,
ich betone, ohne auch nur einen einzigen Service zu haben zu Hause, den er benutzen kann bzw.
benutzen will. Da ist kein Wiki drauf, da ist keine, was weiß ich, Kochrezeptenliste
drauf, kein Nextcloud, wenn das Leute haben wollen, nichts. Das ist einfach nur ultrakomplexes
Setup für das Setup, um das Setup zu managen und Manager für die Manager zu haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Juju ist. Wie gesagt, irgendwas von Ubuntu, irgendwas von
Canonical, glaube ich, und ich habe keine Ahnung, was das... Alter, was geht denn jetzt
ab? Sack.
Okay, lass mal überlegen. Was sehe ich denn hier? Das ist LXC, oder? Oder ist das Snap?
Ich glaube, das ist LXC, also wahrscheinlich einfach nur irgendein Containersymbol. Dieser
Delfin... Warte mal, war das MySQL mit dem Delfin? Was war das nochmal mit dem Delfin-Logo?
Oh, MySQL-Logo. Ja, das ist es mit dem Delfin, ist MySQL. MySQL und die anderen Logos sagen
mir nichts. Was verschickst du auch Software an deine Zuschauer? Hä? Wo sollte ich Software
verschicken? Kannst du einfach runterladen, oder was, oder wie, oder? Das verstehe ich
jetzt nicht. Okay, okay, jetzt hat er noch einen Ceph-Cluster.
Ceph ist ein Distributed File System. Der hat einen OS-Keystone-Cluster. Ich habe keine
Ahnung, was das ist, ehrlich gesagt. MySQL-Cluster und Horizon-Cluster. Horizon kenne ich auch
nicht. Also, der hat da schon einen sehr abgetretenen Stack am Start. Und übrigens, immer noch
angemerkt, er hat alles das hier, ohne auch nur einen einzigen Dienst bei sich zu Hause
laufen zu haben, den er am Ende auch benutzen kann.
Ah, natürlich Elastic Search, Kibana und SubX brauchst du auch noch logisch.
Okay, ich gucke jetzt mal, wo Part 2 ist. Part 2. Part 2 gibt's nicht. Ach, hier, ich
glaube, hier zeigt er gar nicht so viele. Jetzt ist er bloß am rum. Ach, das ist Mars,
guck mal. Das ist Mars. Das ist so Nischenzeug, das habe ich noch nie gesehen und verwendet.
Das ist so ein Ubuntu-Zeug, das glaube ich sonst keiner benutzt. Dann hat er irgendwelche...
Alter, was ist denn das? Irgendeine YAML-Config für sein Zeug? Ja, ist klar, Kollege, ist
klar. Und am Ende hat er immer noch nichts laufen, was er eigentlich daheim verwenden
will. Alles klar. Richtig Biggest Brain. Ist das Log4j? Ja, das ist Log4j. Wisst ihr,
was ich zu Log4j sage? Ich sage zu Log4j, gut, dass ich Urlaub bis Januar habe. Weil
wir haben relativ viel Java auf der Arbeit und ich bin mir sicher, da müssen die Leute
patchen wie verrückt gerade. 100 pro, 100 pro. Warte mal, ich gucke mal kurz in meine
Mails rein. Sekunde. Ich kann euch jetzt natürlich nichts genaues vorlesen, aber. Jaja, die letzte
Meldung, die letzte Meldung, die ich bekommen habe, weil ich abwesend Teams bin, ist, es
werden gerade noch Logfiles beobachtet bei gravierenden Auffälligkeiten blablabla. Also,
Logfiles beobachtet wahrscheinlich, weil irgendwelche Patches Patches rausgehauen haben, keine Ahnung.
Neue Fixes haben wir hier am Start, neue Fixes, Produktion Fixes, Dienstag. Okay, ich habe
jetzt nichts von Log4j. Ich suche jetzt mal in meinem, Moment, ich suche mal kurz in
meinem, in meiner Inbox nach Log4j. Log4j. Oh. Okay. Irgendwie 200 E-Mails gefunden
oder so. Aha, aha. Ach, keine Ahnung, die soll man machen. Ich bin froh, dass ich Urlaub
habe. Lul. Ja, ich will es gar nicht genau wissen. Weißt du, wie Log4j entdeckt wurde?
Habe ich gesagt, keine Ahnung. Ich habe mich damit nicht beschäftigt. Das einzige, was
ich mir gestern angeguckt habe, ist das hier. Ganz kurz den Heißartikel dazu. Sag mal, wie
hast du deine Link-Shortener installiert? Ich habe gar keine Link-Shortener. Was meinst
du denn für einen Link-Shortener? Ich habe keinen Link-Shortener. Wozu soll ich einen
Link-Shortener haben? Das ist, ach, eine Sicherheitslücke in Minecraft, dachten die. Das ist nicht von
mir. Das hat der Sebaro installiert. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Keine Ahnung. Das
ist nicht von mir. Das habe ich nicht gemacht. Das hat der Sebaro irgendwann mal aufgesetzt.
Ich habe damit nichts zu tun, auch wenn es so aussieht, als ist die Domain von mir. Also
die Domain ist nicht von mir. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Da müssen wir den Sebaro fragen,
aber der Sebaro ist in letzter Zeit irgendwie ziemlich beschäftigt. Log von Jay, das wurde
in Minecraft gefunden. Tatsächlich. Tja. Jetzt noch mal eine Frage, Chat, weiß das jemand
von euch? Ist Log von Jay, Log von Jay, ist das Standard Library oder ist das irgendwie
eine, guck mal, wenn da sogar die Tagesschau drüber berichtet oder ist das eine zusätzliche
Library? Okay, das ist was Zusätzliches. Also das ist wahrscheinlich was so Beliebtes.
Ach, das ist Standard. Nee. Zusätzlich. Okay, das ist die Standard Library, aber ist so
beliebt, dass es quasi mehr oder weniger jedes Projekt verwendet. Ja. Das ist so was wie
bei NPM, die Packages is odd is even. Die gibt es ja auch. Weil, oh guck mal, es gibt
sogar ein Package is odd or even. Mind blown, Alter, NPM. Jetzt geht es aber ab hier. Es
ist, ich mein, es ist halt mal typisch JavaScript, warum es dafür überhaupt ein Package geben
muss. Ich mein, es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es nicht irgendwie einen eingebauten Operator
oder so, um rauszubekommen, ob was odd or even ist. Aber da braucht man anscheinend so
eine Funktion für. Schau mal das hier, Log von Jay Attack Surface. Log von Jay Impact
on Manufacturers and Components Summary. Okay, also Apple. Apple is betroffen. Weiß
es nicht so genau, was ich da sehe. Meme XD. Okay, der Typ weiß schon mal Bescheid. Es
ist ja fast alles betroffen irgendwie. Ja gut, Unify ist klar, das ist komplett Java
Stels. Wisst ihr, was das Gute ist? Ich hab keine Public Java Software im Internet hängen.
Also kein Problem. Ich meine, ich verwende Java Zeug. Ich hab zum Beispiel in Unify Server
laufen, aber der ist nicht von extern erreichbar. Insofern gar kein Problem. Wenn man das allerdings
im Internet hat, ist es natürlich Paynes Champ. xDxD. Alles klar, xDxD. Okay, es gibt
eine extra Memesite für Log von Jay. Alles klar, da weiß man mal, hat es geschafft.
Anscheinend ja. Okay. Recroll. Ich dachte, ich werde jetzt gerecrollt. Log von Jay Recap.
Wenn im Unpaid folks maintain code, ja das ist leider normal im großen Teilen. Tja.
Ja, bin ich froh, dass ich kein Java Zeug am Start habe. Easy. Easy. Zumindest kein öffentliches
Java Zeug, was ich am Start hätte. Habt ihr irgendwas? Also bei uns auf der Arbeit muss
wahrscheinlich die Hölle los sein. Ja, aber die kommt man aber auch nicht öffentlich
dran. Bei uns auf der Arbeit muss wahrscheinlich die Hölle los sein, deswegen denke ich mal
so viel Java Shit, wie wir haben.
Wieso verbreitet jemand mit Excel VBA? MonkaS. Warum sollte man dann sowas machen? Manchmal
hat man keine Chancen und kommt nicht drumherum. Das Windows Terminal ist besser. Aber ich
verwende trotzdem öfters noch das hier. Warum, bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, ehrlich
gesagt. Wenn demnächst der Mars Rover von irgendeiner Klippe fährt, dann wissen wir,
es liegt ein Log von Jay. So, was können wir uns als nächstes angucken? Wie gut ist
die Witcher 2 in Battlefield? What happened? Influencer. So war Abitur im Online-Unterricht.
Das ist neun Minuten. Das wurde mir vorgeschlagen. Das wollte ich mir eben mal angucken. Keine
Ahnung, ob das war. Ich hab nur reingemacht und festgestellt, es sind irgendwelche lustigen
Animationen. Mal gucken, was der sagt. Keine Ahnung, kenn das nicht. Wahrscheinlich sagt
er, dass Online-Unterricht sackt. Okay. MonkaS. Das ist für meinen Boomer hier zu schnell
geschnitten. Da komm ich nicht mit. FVBA, das ist Visual Basic for Applications. Klasse.
Nur bei mir, Abi-Jahrgang 2021, gingen diese zwei Jahre oder auch vier Semester vom Ende
2019, kurz bevor diese besonderen Umstände anfingen, bis Mitte 2021, wo es jetzt Impfungen
gibt, das Timing an. Also, wie sahen diese vier... Alter. Please, nicht einfach jede
halbe Sekunde in den Schnitt. Ich komm nicht mehr mit. Das ist zu viel für mich. Ich bin
da zu alt für...... aber wichtigsten halb Jahre meiner gesamten
Schullaufbahn aus. Und wie waren die Prüfungen am Ende? Das erste Semester war ganz normal.
Es war halt 2019. Doch dann kam das zweite Halbjahr. Es ging langsam an. Mit Masken und
Lüften, während alles andere schon zu machte. Ja, das fand ich ja auch geil. Wie ewig die
gebraucht haben, in den Schulen da mal irgendwas zu machen. Und es gab ja damals schon Anfang
2020 war das, also irgendwie April 2020, da wo es losging, haben mir die Leute schon gesagt,
es wäre nicht sinnvoll, irgendwelche Luft, nicht Luftbefeuchter, so Luftfilter in die
Schulen zu stellen. Und das hat man bis heute irgendwie nicht richtig hinbekommen.
Aber dann passierte was und ich kann mich so gut dran erinnern. Ich saß zu Hause, hatte
halt ein paar Freistunden, war gerade kurz... Lass mich raten. Es hat jemand angerufen
und hat gesagt, Schule fällt aus, weil nur noch Homeschooling. Alter, das ist ja das
krasseste Zoomer-Video, was ich je gesehen habe. Wie? Warum ist er denn noch in die Schule
gegangen, wenn es als daheim stattfindet? Ach so. Ja. Ist das Chat? Ihr seid da näher
dran? Hattet ihr auch noch Lehrer? Also sogar ich hatte, wie gesagt, ich bin 1984 geboren
und bei mir ist schon ein bisschen her. Also sogar ich hatte in der Berufsschule Lehrer,
die komplett auf Overhead-Projektor geschwört haben. So, die Sache ist plus sie ist es 13
bzw. 14 Jahre später. Und ich hatte damals auch Lehrer, die haben immer Schüler gebraucht,
die für sie den Videorekorder einschalten und sowas. Es ist unglaublich. Wir sind das
Problem daran ist gar nicht mal so sehr die Lehre an sich, sondern ich glaube, dass wir
in Deutschland allgemein ziemlich technikfeindlich sind. Das sehe ich auch an meiner Verwandtschaft
und sonst wie. So nach dem Motto, wenn man das nicht unbedingt dazu gezwungen wird, dann
verwendet man es nicht. Also für die Leute sind quasi, was weiß ich, Tickets, Bahntickets
auf dem Handy kaufen ist für 95 Prozent der Leute habe ich das Gefühl in Deutschland
Hexenwerk. Wieso? Werden aus dem Nichts dazu gezwungen, ihren gesamten Abitur relevanten
Unterricht online zu machen. Also für alles, was klar war, dass es chaotisch wird. Ja,
das habe ich mir schon gedacht. Übrigens, der macht da wirklich gute Animation, aber
es ist Superschnitt extrem. Wisst ihr, was ich witzig finde? Ein Kollege von mir auf
der Arbeit hat eine Tochter, glaube ich, ist in Kolumbien. Ja, da war man bei der
Armee und hat sich da fortgepflanzt und so. Wahrscheinlich muss er da immer noch Unterhalt
bezahlen. Zumindest ist es egal. Er hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien, Kollege von mir auf
der Arbeit, und er hat mir erzählt, die machen schon seit irgendwie einem halben Jahr Remote-Unterricht
und es funktioniert einfach. Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, warum kriegt das Kolumbien
hin, was jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so für wahnsinnige, ja, das Technik-Aushängeschild
der Welt vielleicht ist und wir überhaupt nicht. Wie kann das sein? Naja.
Bei uns war es aber eine große Cloud für alles. Jede Klasse hatte eigene Ordner für
alle Fächer, auch die Oberstufe. Wie Hausaufgaben funktioniert haben, war dann so. In den Ordnern
der Fächer waren dann... Okay, lass mich raten, lass mich raten. Okay,
Prediction, Leute, Prediction. Das ist irgendein Online-Ordner, wahrscheinlich am besten
auch per FDP oder sowas. So, und pass mal auf, ich rate jetzt einfach mal, die Ordner
sind nicht personalisiert. Also du siehst wahrscheinlich alles, was da jeder jemals
reingetroppt hat. Die Fs mit Infos, Hausaufgaben. Und, und, du kannst anderen Leuten Sachen
löschen. Deadlines. Man macht dann irgendwann die Hausaufgaben, fotografiert sie und gibt
sie auf. Seriously. Irgendwann die Hausaufgaben, fotografiert sie. Man könnte ja die Hausaufgaben
direkt am Rechner machen, aber nee, nee, das ist dann nicht oldschool genug. Nein,
man muss sie fotografieren. Und gibt sie ab. Aber da gab es einige lustige
Fehler. Ganz kurz, falls einer meiner Lehrer das Video hier sieht, alle hier erwähnten
Dinge habe ich in Wirklichkeit nie selbst ausgenutzt. Ich würde ja nie was Unerlaubtes
machen. Hey, ist das ein Kind, das influent? Puh. Auf jeden Fall gab es in der Zeit einige
Highlights. Bei vielen Fächern war die Abgabe von Hausaufgaben anfangs in Abgabeordnern
in der Cloud. Und die waren öffentlich zugänglich. Ja, genau. Ja. Das heißt, jeder konnte reinschauen.
Also konnte ich sehen, was jeder vor mir abgegeben hatte. Und wahrscheinlich konnte auch alles
löschen. Das klassische. Ey Bro, kannst du mir bitte die Hausaufgaben für morgen schicken?
Okay. Danke man. Nur ohne nachzufragen. Und ja, man konnte sich sehr leicht inspirieren
lassen. Und oh boy, hat man sich da viel inspirieren lassen können. Und wenn das nicht genug
gewesen wäre, ein netter Bonus war auch im Ordner stand bei den Abgaben auch nur die
Uhrzeit, wo die Datei erstellt wurde. Nicht, da konnte man auch ein bisschen. Das heißt,
im Endeffekt, man konnte in der Theorie schätze einfach eine leere Datei hochladen können
und sagen Ja, ja, Rest kommt gleich. Bist mitgenommen, hat man ihn aber nicht. Vielleicht
nicht so gut für die Abschlussprüfungen. Dazu komme ich aber später. Was anderes,
was durch Homeschooling viel häufiger aufkam, waren technische Probleme oder auch wie ich
sie nenne technische Probleme. Und ihr könnt es euch vielleicht denken oder habt es vielleicht
auch selbst gemacht? Du hast deine Hausaufgaben nicht abgegeben. Sorry, technische Probleme.
Kannst du bitte die Frage beantworten? Technische Probleme, technische Probleme, Datum 22. Das
Beste ist ja, da können die Lehrer noch nicht mal was dagegen sagen, weil es kann dir halt
jederzeit passieren. Also mein Internet in Deutschland ist ja so eine Sache. Es kann
dir jederzeit passieren, dass entweder ein Rechner Probleme macht oder deine Internetleitung
nicht richtig funktioniert. Technische Probleme? Jawoll! Diese zwei Wörter. Es war OP und das
ist echt nicht so selten passiert. Es gab aber auch Leute, die wirklich Probleme hatten und
es sogar beweisen konnten, aber die Lehrer es trotzdem nicht geglaubt haben. Das war
dann echt nicht okay. Ich habe das Glück, gut funktionierende Geräte zu haben und selbst
bei mir gab es ab und zu echte Probleme. Und die Schul Cloud hat auch einige Crashes erlebt.
Schultechnik halt. Was nicht so cool war, waren gelegentlich Videokonferenzen. Viele denken,
hey, nur sitzen und zuhören, chillig. Aber ich finde... Alter, das ist das krasseste Zooma-Video,
was ich je gesehen habe von den Schnitten. Das muss ja alle Sekunde irgendwie wechseln.
Extrem anstrengend. Noch mehr als wirkliche Schule. Die ganzen schlechten Mikrofone hören an um 8 Uhr.
Ja, das ist nicht nur in der Schule. Das ist Homeoffice auf der Arbeit genauso. Dass du denkst,
die Leute sind unter Wasser mit ihrem Mikrofon oder haben den oder haben keine Ahnung,
haben das Mikrofon im Arsch stecken oder so. Und der Leerstoff wird nur extrem trocken und
uninteressant beigebracht. Als wäre es ein extrem langweiliger Streamer. Und in Kombination mit
meinem schlechten Schlafrhythmus bin ich häufig... Im Prinzip sind Lehrer auch extrem langweilige
Streamer, wenn man die sich daheim angucken muss....ein geschlafen. Zum Glück war bei mir Webcam-Nieppflicht.
Zum Beispiel in Geschichte. Ich hör nur... Tschüss. Panic-Kurz. Sag... Tschüss. Und ging
weiter schlafen. Okay, vielleicht war es doch nicht so schlimm. War dann aber nur für Klausuren
vorbereitet. Wie die abliefen, sage ich später. Einmal im Bio war es aber so. Für diese Aufgabe
teilt euch alle in Gruppen ein. Ich war aber am schlafen. Und als ich aufgewacht bin,
war keiner im Call. Oh, ich muss in eine Gruppe. Dann habe ich aber gelesen, die Lehrerin hat
mir vor 10 Minuten geschrieben, Halt Ziel, warum bist du nicht in einer Gruppe? Lass mich raten,
technische Probleme? Oh no. Ich habe dann einfach irgendwas geschrieben, keine Ahnung,
technische Probleme oder so. Später waren dann wieder alle in einem Call, Gruppenergebnisse wurden
verglichen. Kurz Augen zugemacht. Boom. Ich bin wieder allein im Call. Die Stunde ist seit 12
Minuten vorbei. Ups. Frag mich, was sich die Lehrerin gedacht hat. Und genau weil Videokonferenzen
gigalangweilig sind, haben wir währenddessen öfters auf Discord gechillt. Denn wir hatten
eine 11. Klasse... Genau das hätte ich auch gemacht, wäre ich heute da in der Schule gewesen. Ich hätte
einen Discord-Server gemacht, hätte gesagt, Jungs, lasst einfach alle außer dem Lehrer natürlich in
den Discord-Server rein. Im Zweifelsfall kann man dann auch gut, also die beste Sache zu faken ist ja,
wenn man keine Ahnung hat, aber in einem Discord ist und jemand anderes schnell was reinschreiben
kann. Und wenn das gegenseitig passiert, ist das ja auch nicht schlimm. Also das erste, was ich
gemacht hätte, ich hätte einen Discord gemacht. Niemals.
Leute, ich kann mich richtig vorstellen, wir hatten ja auch so Spezialleute bei uns in der Klasse,
die sind dann auch immer vorne, haben dem Lehrer geholfen, Projektor anzuschließen und so was. Das
wären die ersten gewesen, die gesagt hätten hier, ich muss mir jetzt irgendwie was ausringen, hier
Frau Lehrerin, wussten Sie eigentlich, dass der Max und der Stefan und der Christoph und der Dennis,
dass die eigentlich nebenbei im Discord sind und Spiele spielen? 100%, ich kann es mir so richtig
vorstellen, ich kann es mir so richtig vorstellen, dass das erstmal richtig, dass das erstmal groß
gepetzt worden wäre. Hä? Moment, was? Jetzt habe ich nicht gecheckt. Ach, er hat Minecraft
gespielt und er hat dann sich nicht gemutet. Okay, verstehe. Das ist aber noch was ganz
wichtiges. Klausuren. Ein Drittel bis eine Hälfte der Note in einem Fach. Im zweiten
halben Jahr war es so, Klausuren wurden in der Regel online geschrieben. Genau, von zu Hause aus
am PC. Man hat die Klausurabgaben per Mail bekommen und eine Abgabe bezahlt. Keine Videokamera. Hä?
Per Mail? Obwohl sie irgendwelche Ablageordner hatten. Egal, egal, per Mail. Das gibt aber
unglaublich viel Beschisspotenzial. Aber gut, was willst du machen? Keine Videokamera. Soll
ich euch mal sagen, wenn man Zertifizierungen macht, die haben das gleiche Problem. Zum Beispiel,
du machst ein Microsoft Azure Zertifikat oder sowas. Die haben genau das gleiche Problem. Du
sitzt daheim, du kriegst die Prüfung freigeschaltet und könntest ja theoretisch am zweiten Rechner und
irgendwo nachgucken. Wisst ihr, was die machen? Du musst Desktop Übertragung machen, du musst dich
filmen und es ist verboten, dass irgendjemand anderes auf der Kamera zu sehen ist, außer du,
sonst fällst du instant durch. Es darf nichts Verdächtiges passieren. Es gibt Leute, die haben
gesagt, sie schließen sich im, also kein Scheiß, das habe ich wirklich von Leuten gehört, die
Azure Prüfung gemacht haben. Sie haben sich im Klo eingeschlossen, dass nicht zufällig jemand
reinkommt. Webcam an und im Klo eingeschlossen. Du darfst nichts machen, ja. Du darfst nichts
machen. Sonst gleich Fake und sonst was. Und ich wette mit euch, es wird trotzdem beschissen. Ich
glaube, du musst vorher auch deinen Raum zeigen und sowas. Und die haben wahrscheinlich für jeden
Prüfling da auch einen, der die Kamera beobachtet. Keine Bildschirmübertragung, keine Kontrolle. Aber
es gab ja eh nichts, was man in der Zeit hätte machen können. Google. Hat aber leider in vielen
Fällen wirklich nicht so viel gebracht, habe ich gehört. Im vierten Halbjahr, wo der Unterricht
komplett online stattfand, war es aber so, es wurden keine Klausuren, außer in zwei Fächern
geschrieben. Wisst ihr, was das einfachste wäre, wenn man mit der Zeit gehen würde? Man würde seine
Arbeiten, also das geht jetzt nur bei Mathe und sowas natürlich gut. Man würde seine Arbeiten
einfach randomisieren. Also es bekommen alle die gleichen Arbeiten, aber die Reihenfolge der
Fragen ist randomisiert und die Inputwerte sind randomisiert. Weil ob ich jetzt in Mathe 5 plus
5 rechne oder 4 plus 4, wisst ihr, ich meine, das ist erstmal wurscht. Es würde sogar reichen,
die Zahlen einfach nur zu vertauschen. Du müsstest, das macht die Prüfung halt nicht schwerer und
nicht leichter. Im Endeffekt kriegst du randomisierte Zahlen und randomisierte Aufgabenreihenfolgen.
Die Aufgaben an sich bleiben aber gleich. Dann wäre es zumindest ein bisschen weniger,
dass du abgucken könntest. Ja, kontrollieren zu viel Arbeit, das stimmt. Aber es gibt bestimmt
Software, mit der man das relativ easy machen kann, die das dann alles für dich schon vorher
ausrechnet. Zumindest ist es das erste, was mir einfällt. Ich denke, da gibt es noch deutlich
bessere Varianten. Okay, alles bisher erwähnte klingt sogar ziemlich gut. Aber was wirklich
schlimm am Online-Unterricht war, man musste sich fast alles am Ende selbst beibringen und
einfach trocken Arbeitsblätter abarbeiten. Statt halbwegs interaktiver Unterricht ist echt
langweilig. Und wie man es kennt, vor allem mit Zoom aufmerksamkeitsspanne. So welche hatten wir
auch. Jedes Mal, wenn es geklingelt hat und der Typ nicht fertig war, hat er gesagt, Leute,
sitzen bleiben. Das Klingelzeichen ist ein wager Hinweis für den Lehrer. Er möge bitte den
Unterricht innerhalb der nächsten 15 Minuten beenden. Kann ich mich bis heute noch daran
erinnern. Das hat er jedes Mal von sich gegeben. Also, Alter, wir müssen jetzt rüber. Wir müssen
danach irgendwie ins andere Gebäude laufen und sonst was. Nein, das Klingelzeichen ist ein wager
Hinweis für den Lehrer. Er möge den Unterricht in den nächsten 15 Minuten beenden. Deswegen hat man
manchmal viel zu viele Aufgaben bekommen. Und von Lehrer zu Lehrer hat sich das viel zu stark
unterschieden. Manche haben sogar extra viele Aufgaben gegeben und geschrieben, hier, damit
ihr euch nicht zu Hause langweilt. Wow, danke. Ich hatte aber auch eine Lehre, da gab es mega viele
Aufgaben. Aber hier sind die Aufgaben. Die Abgabe ist aber freiwillig. Okay, haben sicherlich ganz
viele gemacht. Ich hatte in dem Fach eine 4. Am Ende kamen dann die Prüfungen. Ein Drittel der
Abiturnote. Der Lernstoff der ganzen letzten zwei Jahre wird abgefragt. Und wir sind da auch...
Weißt du, was ich auch cool finde? Wenn dann nur der Lernstoff der letzten zwei Jahre abgefragt
wird, was ja gut ist, du kannst ja gar nicht alles. Aber im Endeffekt musst du dich in der Schule nur
zwei Jahre anstrecken. Davor kannst du es eigentlich komplett vergessen. Also zumindest war es bei mir
ähnlich. Ich weiß doch, ich glaube, ich habe nichts gemacht bis quasi das Jahr, wo ich dann
einen Abschluss gemacht habe. Ich glaube, so das Minimalste wie ich kann man gar nicht machen.
Die Sachen bauen auch nur zum Teil aufeinander auf.
Ja, genau. Ach weißt, die Schule hat eh gesagt. Es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, also mein Opa
beispielsweise hat immer zu mir gesagt, hier warte mal ab, bis du arbeiten musst, dann wirst
dir wünschen, wieder in die Schule gehen zu können. Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das ist nie passiert.
Ich wünsche mir weder mich in die Berufsschule zurück, noch in die normale Schule. Ich wünsche
mir vielleicht zurück, dass es coole Zeiten, die es gegeben hat damals, aber nicht die Schule an
sich. So als Schule war der größte Shit überhaupt. Dumme Sachen passiert. Ich werde jetzt nicht über
alle fünf Abschlussprüfungen reden, außer ihr wollt es sich irgendwann tun. Aber einer meiner
Abi-Prüfungen war natter. Und ich weiß, dass viele von euch vom Fach halten. Aber ey, ich bin
eigentlich ziemlich gut im Natter. Und wegen den Besondern. Als hätte ich es gewusst, dass jetzt
irgendwie high IQ big brain meme kommt. Ich wusste es irgendwie instinktiv. Und wegen den besonderen
Umständen kam Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung, mein schlechtes Thema, nicht dran. Und man hat gut viel
Bonuszeit bekommen. Also waren das schon mal echt gute Voraussetzungen für die Prüfung. Ich habe
die Prüfung also geschrieben. Habe sogar ein echt gutes Gefühl dabei. Bin fertig geworden. Guck auf
die Uhr. Hab noch gut Zeit übrig. Denk mir noch. Yo, let's go. Das ist meine allerletzte schriftliche
Prüfung oder Test oder Arbeit meiner gesamten Schullaufbahn. Dann bin ich noch mal alle Aufgaben
durchgegangen und hab sie kontrolliert. Und packt die Blätter alle zusammen. Ist überall mein Name drauf.
Sagt er eins, zwei, drei und vier. Ah und hier die letzte Seite. Wie? Es gibt eine Rückseite? Da sind drei
Aufgaben drauf. Komm schalte ich das mal an. Electrical Information. Und genau dann. Ihr habt noch eine Minute. Okay, das war's.
Ich bin stupend. In dieser einen Minute habe ich es nicht mal mehr versucht. Habe nur noch gezählt wie
viele Punkte es insgesamt gab und wie viele ich wegen der Rückseite verloren habe. Mir ist sowas noch
nie passiert. Also Rückseite übersehen. Und dann passiert es mir genau in meiner letzten Arbeit. Ja, war ganz
fein. Ich bin nur ein Idiot. Hatte sonst nur einen Fehler. Bei den anderen Abi-Prüfungen waren die Noten
aber eigentlich auch so wie immer. Trotz der besonderen Umstände. Für viele andere in Berlin
wurden sie sogar auch besser. Und ganz wichtig, ich habe mein Abitur bestanden. Ich war aber auch einfach
echt lucky. Gut, dass die Lehrer alle von Technik, keine Ahnung, ist keiner rumgerannt. Hey ist das ein
Handy? Also ich, äh, abonniere den Kanal. Sonst überziehst du bald auch eine Rückseite. Ja, stellt euch mal vor, die Lehrer werden da
durchblicken. Wo kämen wir dann dahin? Aber ich glaube, das muss so sein. Lehrer, Lehrer müssen aus
Prinzip bei Technik nicht durchblicken. Was sehr merkwürdig ist, weil ich dachte mir eigentlich so
in meinem Boomerhirn damals, wo ich in die Schule gegangen bin und die Lehrer schon so unfähig waren,
habe ich mir gedacht, Mensch das muss doch ganz cool sein, wenn in 20 Jahren oder so die Lehrer
dann auch mal Ahnung von Technik haben. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass die Lehrer jetzt auch keine Ahnung
von Technik haben und ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Wie gut, ich, ich, okay, wenn's Spoiler frei ist, ist es okay.
Ja, richtig viele, nice Witz. Brainfuck in 100 Sekunden, Leute, was haltet ihr davon?
Das muss jetzt sein, oder? Brainfuck in 100 Sekunden, auf geht's. Ich finde das lustig,
dass er Brainfuck sagt, aber das Gepiepe kommt nicht bei Fuck. Das Piepsen ist komplett,
komplett out of sync. Brainfuck, a minimal esoteric. Okay.
Ich gebe, ich gebe dir einen Tipp. Ich gebe dir einen Tipp. Wenn du gerade schon dabei bist und
nicht das alles so anmach, dann kannst du mir einfach ein Prime-Sub dalassen. Da ist das noch viel besser.
Also, also, nur dass ich jetzt richtig verstehe, das da oder so ist ein gültiges Brainfuck-Programm.
Easy. Ja, variabel ist ja auch bloat. Gibt es, gibt es eine Visual Studio Code, Code Highlighting
Extension für Brainfuck? Ah, yes.
Alles klar. Okay, jetzt ist mir auch zum ersten Mal klar geworden, warum das Brainfuck heißt.
Das ist dafür gemacht, um es nicht zu verstehen. Ach du Scheiße. Da muss er
wirklich massive, ultra-extrem-brain sein. Also, normales Hirn reicht dafür gar nicht aus mehr.
Wahnsinn, ETF. Ein paar Einsteiger-Dinger könnten wir wirklich mal machen.
Ich dachte, ich dachte jetzt werde ich gerecrollt oder so.
Nein, wir haben das Battlefield-Timeline-Video noch nicht gesehen. Jetzt könnten wir theoretisch
als nächstes gucken. Das könnten wir tatsächlich als nächstes gucken. Weißt du, wie man
Lautsprecher-Fiepen wegbekommt? Na ja, die eigentliche Frage ist ja, wo es herkommt.
Brummen kriegst du manchmal weg, indem du mal die unterschiedlichen Steckdosen durchprobierst.
War die im Zimmer? Aber Fiepen, das ist ja meistens irgendwelche Spulen oder so. Einfach
Heißkleber drauf. Nö, keine Ahnung. Die Frage, wo es herkommt. Aber Heißkleber fixt im Zweifelsfall
alles. Was soll ich anschauen als Battlefield-Video?
Pork, danke für den Sub. So muss es sein. Dann gucken wir jetzt, dass Battlefield wird.
Also, wer den nicht kennt, das ist der Typ, der so ziemlich alles geleakt hat in den vergangenen
zwei Jahren, was Battlefield angeht. Der hat auch viele Sachen, interne Sachen, Call of
Duty Zeug geleakt. Der ist dafür eigentlich schon relativ bekannt. Der hier. Dass er immer
irgendwelche Sachen schon vorher weiß. Und er hat ein Video gemacht mit den Ereignissen
von Anfang bis jetzt zu der Battlefield 2042 Entwicklung und an welchen Stellen es verkackt
wurde. Gucken wir das mal an. Ich check. Es könnte sein, dass ich das auf YouTube hochlade,
falls das ein gutes Video ist, beziehungsweise ich was irgendwie Sinnvolles dazu sagen kann.
Also könnt ihr einmal alle Hallo YouTube in den Chat hauen, falls das was wird. Du musst
die Lautstärke vorher checken. Das mach ich diesmal vorher. Okay, viel zu leise.
Okay, so jetzt fangen wir an. Das Intro überspring ich, weil das Intro das haut mega
rein.
Okay, sorry, das muss ich jetzt beahlen. Das ist mittlerweile ganz schlimm. Die Leute
müssen immer einen riesen Disclaimer am Anfang von den Videos machen. So nach dem Motto,
ich kritisiere jetzt was, aber Leute, ihr müsst mich nicht haten dafür. Ich finde es
schlimm, dass das überhaupt notwendig ist. Die Leute sind einfach so krass schnell getriggert
mittlerweile, dass man immer schon davor quasi erstmal eine Runde in Watte packen muss. Bevor
man so nach dem Motto, Achtung, gleich kommt ein wenig was, was ich kritisiere. Achtung
Achtung!
Aber wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich habe mir aufgefallen, dass Orbital die einzige Map ist, die so einen Event hat wie
mit der Rakete. Bei den anderen war anscheinend keine Zeit mehr.
Alter, übertreib es halt! MonkaS!
Alter, ich kenne Kristen doch nicht.
Many of those senior figures that founded the company actually left during Battlefield 5's development with non-competition clauses.
The five founders of Embark Studios alone had an impressive combined experience of 91 years at DICE,
and with other people leaving the studio as well to founder either new studios or join existing studios,
it was instantly clear that Battlefield 2042 lacked the experience of Battlefield developers.
The majority of these figures left DICE for one simple reason.
That being creative, they were not the most successful players in the game,
but the majority of these figures were the most successful players in the game,
and the majority of these figures were the most successful players in the game.
The majority of these figures left DICE for one simple reason.
Time and time again developers would pitch impressive ideas that were ahead of its time,
but with EA wanting to compete against the competition instead of getting ahead of it,
many senior developers simply had enough and wanted their own creative freedom.
Die Sache ist halt die, nur weil du eine coole neue Idee hast, heißt es nicht automatisch, dass es einschlagen wird wie Bombe.
Na das ist vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich jetzt, äh, hatte das ein bisschen missverständlich gesagt, also ich mein, ähm,
wenn du Sachen nachbaust, die erfolgreich sind, ist die Chance, dass das klappt, wahrscheinlich höher, als wenn du was komplett Neues versuchst und, äh,
dann überhaupt keine Daten hast und überhaupt nicht weißt, was da überhaupt abgeht.
Naja, aber es ist natürlich als Entwickler tatsächlich ziemlich kacke, wenn du nur Trends hinterher rennst,
anstatt dich selbst da irgendwie ein bisschen verwirklichen zu können.
EA already had their eyes set on the next big thing within the gaming world, and that of course was Battle Royale.
Of course, at this time, there was also Battlefield V's Firestorm in development by DICE,
in collaboration with Criterion Games. However, due to Battlefield V's poor sales,
it was expected that Firestorm wasn't going to get the desired effect that EA wanted for its post-launch sales.
But that mainly came down to its competition with the likes of Fortnite, PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds,
H1Z1 and even Black Ops 4's Blackout Battle Royale, all dominating the gaming market.
Combining this with the fact that many senior figures who were working on Battlefield V were now leaving the studio...
Das war dieser sehr kontroverse, ultra-diverse diversity trailer von Battlefield V,
wo sie, könnt ihr euch noch an dieses Event erinnern, wo sie am Anfang eine halbe Stunde erzählt haben,
dass das das authentischste und genaueste und am besten gemachteste und wie auch immer realistischste, geilste, immersivste,
die haben sich ja nach voll überschlagen, Battlefield aller Zeiten ist, und dann hattest du diesen Trailer,
der für sich genommen gar nicht schlecht war, aber der überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hatte, was die im Vorfeld erzählt haben.
Also da haben sie sich selbst richtig hart ins Bein geschossen.
Ey Apex, Apex macht denen so krass Kohle.
...Respawn Entertainment, die eine Free-To-Play Battle Royale auf den Markt gebracht haben, mit keinem Format Marketing,
wäre viel besser, in Bezug darauf, ihre Playerbase zu steuern und diese Spieler zu konvertieren...
Wusstet ihr, dass sie über eine Milliarde schon verdient haben an Apex? Mittlerweile wahrscheinlich sogar noch deutlich mehr.
...mit ihren Postlaunch-Kontent-Plans.
Eine Milliarde?
Das ist krass.
Das passt auch einfach richtig gut, oder?
Das passt auch mehr zu so einer Art Gameplay als zu einem klassischen Battlefield.
Was ich aber interessant finde, dass das anscheinend vor Specialists da war.
Oh ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Könnt ihr euch doch gerade erinnern, wie die englischsprachigen Content-Creator alle eskaliert sind bei diesem Technical Preview Trailer?
So nach dem Motto hier, Most Immersive Best Battlefield Experience Ever, oh mein Gott, total am Durchdrehen gewesen, obwohl du nix gesehen hast.
Battlefield 5 wurde zum Beispiel im Jahr 2016 auf Frostbite veröffentlicht.
Das war das Jahr, in dem DICE und EA entschieden haben, dass sie das Battlefield upgraden sollten,
insbesondere wegen all den Features und Plans, die sie für diesen Battlefield-Titel hatten.
Aber es wurde erwartet, dass DICE...
Weil die keine Ahnung mehr haben.
Ja.
Die haben sich einfach gedacht, wisst ihr was?
Und sind abgehauen.
Alter, jetzt ist...
Übertreib's halt mit den Intros in der Mitte immer.
Im Februar 2019 explodierte Apex Legends, ein neuer Free-To-Play-Titel, in einem riesigen Überraschungsanlass und wurde von Respawn Entertainment und EA veröffentlicht.
Das Titel hat in den ersten 24 Stunden 2,5 Mio. einzelner Spieler erreicht, mit 50 Mio. einzelner Spieler im ersten Monat.
Obwohl EA endlich das Stück des Battle Royale-Markets hatte, war nicht ganz klar, wie gut Apex Legends aussehen würden.
Jetzt, meine Güte!
Ich hoffe, er zeigt die Concept-Arts der ursprünglichen Soldaten für Battlefield.
Die waren richtig gut im Vergleich zu dem, was jetzt da ist.
Guckt mal, das sieht richtig gut aus. Das sieht viel battlefieldiger aus als die Specialists. Guckt euch das mal an.
Das hat irgendwie einen ernsteren Unterton und das sieht halt nach einem Battlefield...
Ja, keine Ahnung. Soll es der Crabling Hook sein? Ich erkenne es nicht.
Das sieht einfach viel realitätsnah und einfach mehr nach Battlefield aus.
Oh nein.
Und was ist der Effekt davon, dass es irgendwie umbenannt wird, dass es nicht mehr unter die gesetzlichen Regelungen fällt?
Ich glaube, es ist nicht so, dass es nicht mehr unter die gesetzlichen Regelungen fällt, dass es nicht mehr unter die gesetzlichen Regelungen fällt.
Also im Prinzip ist es eigentlich noch schlechter geworden, das System. Oder war es Frankreich? Kann auch Frankreich gewesen sein.
Das ist total wir. Man schlängelt sich quasi in der Grauzone an den Gesetzen vorbei.
Das heißt dann halt nicht mehr Lootboxen, sondern Surprise Mechanics oder was auch immer.
Das ist ein Wettrennen, das werden wir die nächsten Jahre weiter beobachten.
Für seinen Battlefield-Titel. Und das Revenustream würde Specialists sein.
Die gucken quasi, was können wir machen? Okay, was ist der aktuelle Trend? Okay, das machen wir.
Leute, schweißt mal alles über den Haufen. Wir machen jetzt diesen Trend.
Dann wird ein halbes Jahr später festgestellt, ach Mist, was anderes ist super erfolgreich.
Dann machen wir jetzt das. Das muss auch noch irgendwie rein.
Das spiegelt halt das wieder, was man auch bei dem Spielfilm Gefühl hat, dass es eben keine wirklich schlüssige, einheitliche Vision und Konzept gab.
Sondern man einfach nur genommen hat von allen Spielen, was erfolgreich ist.
Man hat Specialists genommen. Man hat irgendwelche Skin-Geschichten genommen.
Man hat Battle-Royale-Style-Maps genommen. Man hat so einen Tarkov-Style-Modus eingebaut.
Dass du quasi so unterschiedliche Stückchen hast am Ende, die eigentlich gar nicht so richtig zusammenpassen.
Und halt komplett auch die Kreativität killen.
Aber...
Aber was man da halt sagen muss, andere Hersteller haben das auch geschafft, Spiele von zuhause zu entwickeln und zu releasen.
Die Sache ist nur die, wenn du natürlich so eine hohe Fluktuation hast wie DICE
und dementsprechend auch viele neue Leute anheuern musst für das Game.
Da haben ja, das wissen wir ja echt, da haben ja, was weiß ich, fünf Studios und was weiß ich, wie viele Hunderde an Leuten oder sogar tausende Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele das insgesamt sind.
Dann ist es natürlich problematisch, weil dann musst du das irgendwie unter einen Hut bekommen.
Und du musst vor allem quasi Leute, wenn du nur Leute, die von daheim arbeiten hast,
du musst auch neue Leute, die keine Ahnung davon haben.
Und wir haben ja gehört, dass sie gerade mit Frostbite auch schon wenig Leute haben, die Ahnung haben.
Die musst du dann irgendwie noch dazu kriegen, Ahnung zu haben.
Und das halt ohne, wie soll man so schön sagen, Hands-On-Geschichten.
Mit Leuten, die Planen haben. Das stelle ich mir dann doch schon relativ schwierig vor.
Und ich glaube, dass umso größer das wird und umso höher die Fluktuation ist,
umso schwieriger ist es, sowas zu managen in einem reinen Homeoffice-Environment.
Was aber letztendlich natürlich, das muss man sagen, das liegt jetzt ja auch nur zum Thailand DICE.
Das ist eine Sache des Managements, die sich um sowas kümmern muss.
Das ist den ihren Job. Dafür sind die da, dafür bekommen sie das.
Wenn sie das nicht geschissen kriegen, ist das erstmal da, die Schuld zu suchen.
Das ist meiner Sicht zumindest.
Wie ist das Internet in Schweden?
Wie? Nicht?
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Also ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass jeder mal mindestens 5 Monitore hat,
2 super krass schnelle Rechner und alle Konsolen der letzten 30 Jahre.
Was sind das denn für Entwickler? Unglaublich.
Was?
Okay, ja dann wundert es mich nicht, dass das nicht richtig funktioniert.
Wie willst du denn Spiele über Remote Desktop gescheit entwickeln?
Dann sollen sie den Dudes halt eine Konsole schicken oder was auch immer.
Da sind wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen Punkt.
Das ist ein Management-Problem.
Das ist ein organisatorisches Problem, was das Management lösen muss. Dafür sind die da.
Das ist den ihren Job und es gibt natürlich auch Low-Latency-Streaming-Geschichten zum entwickeln.
Also ich denke mal, da könnte man durchaus was machen.
Das ist aber eine Management-Geschichte. Die haben es verkackt an der Stelle.
Bei FIFA scheint sie auch zu funktionieren.
Ja, genau das habe ich mir nämlich gedacht.
Wenn du nämlich hohe Fluktuationen hast und du Leute einarbeiten musst, das ist eines der Situationen, wo ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen kann, dass das
vor Ort, wenn du die Sachen einfach so mitbekommst und daheim musst du irgendwelche wirklich so Tutorial-Sessions schedulen, dass das wirklich besser funktioniert vor Ort.
Aber weiterhin, das ist eine Management-Geschichte.
Und hätte man es die letzten Jahre über nicht so verkackt, dann wären denen auch nicht rein, weil sie Leute weggerannt.
Dann wäre das grundsätzliche Problem schon mal gar nicht so schlimm gewesen.
Die ändern ja laufend die Richtung des Games.
Ich meine, du kannst doch nicht permanent irgendeinem Trend hinterherrennen und wieder was umschmeißen und dann denken, da kommt am Ende noch irgendwas ordentliches bei raus.
Das ist das ist original Boris oder ist das original Boris?
Das ist original Boris guck mal, original Boris finde ich sieht mehr Boris aus als aktueller Boris.
Ihr wisst, ne ne ne, falsch ist nicht Kekona, sondern, ah, wo ist er?
Wo ist mein Kekona mit ihm aus? Da, passt gleich viel besser.
Das sieht deutlich, das sieht deutlich ernster und besser aus, wobei das jetzt, das jetzt ja schon in die Richtung, in die Richtung geht.
Ja, jetzt rennen sie Warzone hinterher. Am Anfang sind sie Fortnite hinterher gerannt, dann sind sie Apex hinterher gerannt und jetzt rennen sie Warzone hinterher.
Das kann ja nichts werden, wenn du so viel zerstökelte Dinge zu einem Game am Ende zusammenfügen willst.
Ja, na gut, Hazard Zone. Hazard Zone ist nichts halbes und nichts ganzes.
Hazard Zone wird mal fünf Runden gespielt, hat überhaupt keinen Anreiz weiter zu spielen und danach geht es weiter.
Hazard Zone ist nichts halbes und nichts ganzes. Hazard Zone wird mal fünf Runden gespielt, hat überhaupt keinen Anreiz weiter zu spielen und danach geht es weiter.
Hazard Zone war natürlich ein Free-To-Play-VR-Experiment, aber irgendwo unter der Linie wurde diese Entscheidung überwunden und es wurde eher ein Teil von Battlefield 2042 als ein einziger Entity.
August 2020 ist sehr wichtig für die Entwicklung von Battlefield 2042, denn das ist der Zeitpunkt, an dem die Pre-Produktion auf Battlefield 2042 endete.
Das ist der Zeitpunkt, an dem die Postproduktion keinen Start hätte, alle Konzepte und Ideen wurden beendet und das Spiel würde nicht wirklich wechseln.
Ok, was haben wir jetzt? August, guck mal, August 2020, das ist quasi ungefähr eins bis, naja, sagen wir mal eineinhalb Jahre zum Release.
Stimmt gar nicht wirklich, aber sagen wir mal eineinhalb Jahre, runden wir mal auf. Das ist ja eigentlich nichts, ne?
Was willst du denn, naja.
The production of Battlefield 2042 was only going to last one year and three months, which not only is short for a Battlefield title on this scale,
but it's very short for a title that is being developed in a global pandemic in a working from home environment.
Und eins sieht man daran auch wunderbar an Battlefield 2042, einfach mehr Leute draufschmeißen hilft nicht. Mal gucken, wann das kommt.
Aktuell ist es ja noch nicht der Fall gewesen, dass irgendwie super viele Leute, oder er hat es nicht erwähnt, dass super viele Leute neu eingestellt wurden, aber das kommt ja noch.
Da waren ja, was weiß ich, wie viele hunderte Leute an dem Spiel beteiligt. Und unterschiedlichste Studios.
Und in diesem Zustand ist halt das Ding, wenn du eh schon organisatorische Probleme hast, mehr Leute machen es nicht unbedingt einfacher und besser.
Das ist der Grund, warum so viele Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler in die Studio gegründet sind, um die letzte Hälfte des Entwicklungsprozesses zu machen. Was das Faszinierendste in diesem Video sagt, ist, dass die vaste Mehrheit von dem Projekt nur ein wenig auf der Internet zu suchen kann.
Das sieht einfach so viel besser aus Leute.
Ja, wisst ihr was ich witzig finde? Eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gesagt habe in meinem Beta, ich glaube das war noch in meinem Beta Video, war, warum haben die keine so Environment-Events gemacht, wie das Orbital überflutet wird? Und anscheinend hatten sie genau die Idee, hat es aber nicht ins fertige Spiel geschafft, wie so einiges andere auch.
Guckt euch mal an, das ist Hourglass, wie es sein sollte und vergleicht das mal mit Hourglass, wie es jetzt ist. Du hattest hier, ich meine die Straßen hier, hast du teilweise immer noch, aber das meiste ist davon nicht da.
Da war richtig Leben in der Bude noch, aber nix mehr von übrig geblieben. Es ist jetzt ein bisschen Sandsturm und ein paar Häuser, die beschissen aussehen.
Das ist toll.
In erster Linie sieht man auch, dass die Pre-Produktion von Battlefield 2042 in August 2020 endete. Und wir sollten alle wissen, dass das Rocket-Launch-Internal-Trailer aus dem Jahr 2020 produziert wurde.
Und falls ihr mich nicht glaubt, wissen wir, dass der Soundtrack von dem Trailer aus dem Jahr 2020 produziert wurde.
Das Trailer, welches wir gesehen haben, konnte noch nie vor dem Jahr 2020 produziert werden.
In erster Linie sieht man auch, dass der Soundtrack von dem Trailer aus dem Jahr 2020 produziert wurde.
In erster Linie sieht man auch, dass der Soundtrack von dem Trailer aus dem Jahr 2022 produziert wurde.
oder irgendetwas anderes.
Diese Kommentare wurden von Solomid
auf die Ersumptionen und Ergänzungen
von einigen sehr unbekannten
Leuten an DICE
in ihren neuen Rollen.
Es wird gedacht, dass das Spiel
nicht auf der Bühne ist.
Das ist so eine Mischung aus unterschiedlichen
Fakaten auf
unterschiedlichsten Ebenen und an unterschiedlichsten
Stellen.
In der Mitte des Jahres 2021, aber als
diese Zeit immer näher und näher kam,
war es endlich Zeit für DICE
zu ermitteln und
zusätzliche Hilfe auf dem Projekt zu bitten.
Im März 2021
hat Criterion DICE
offiziell beteiligt und es wurde
bemerkt, dass die Entwicklung
bald verbessern würde. Aber wieder
mit viel Lack von Erfahrung
auf dem neuen Frostbite-Engine...
... war die Entwicklung zu schwierig
und es war sehr schwierig,
eine stabilen Version
von Criterion DICE
auf der Bühne.
Das sind die, denen du diese tolle Fahrzeugphysik
in Battlefield zu verdanken hast.
Weil es keine
liarbste cockpit Sand Dudecesso
war.
so
das heißt diese nochmal dazu gekommen oder wie guck mal das ist noch mal 500
leute dazu gekommen das ist jetzt schon organisatorisch absoluter albtraum das
ding und es klappt hinten und vorne nix und das einfache pure draufschmeißen
von leuten das kann eigentlich nicht funktioniert
Wir waren bereit für die technischen Spieltests, die über die nächsten paar Monate stattfinden werden.
Während Frostbite CTO versucht hat, die Messe zu erarbeiten, hat EA mit ihrem Jun-Marktplan fortgeführt,
die offizielle Reveal-Trailer und die 2042-Official-Multiplayer-Trailer eröffnet,
die in so einem Art und Weise entstanden werden mussten, dass es nicht alle Probleme zeigen würde,
die das Spiel im Moment vorhanden war.
Im Juli 2021 war das Battlefield-2042-Projekt in einer kritischen Situation,
und die UI des Spiels hat das ganze Projekt an Risiken gebracht.
Das UI von Battlefield 2042 ist ja auch herausragend mies.
Allein schon die Sichtbarkeit, ob ein Toggle-Button an oder aus ist,
also wie das da überhaupt durchgekommen ist, ist mir komplett schleierhaft.
Also das User-Interface.
Aber es ist glaubt, dass es zu dem Fakt kommen könnte, dass ein paar Lead-UI-Skripteure die Dice nur ein paar Monate vor den Hauptproblemen verlassen haben und zusätzlich die Dice in einen Kontraktor, den Netlight, in April 2020.
Ungefähr habe ich nicht wirklich so viel Informationen im Moment vorhanden, als warum die UI-Skripteure so schrecklich falsch waren,
aber es könnte erklären, was wir mit der letzten Version des Battlefield-2042 bekommen haben.
August 2021 war natürlich der Monat, in dem der technische Spieltest für das Spiel geschehen ist.
Natürlich hat jeder, der das Spieltest gespielt, den Spiel zu sehr unstaublich und schreckliche Leistungsprobleme gefunden.
Und das war auf der Map Orbital, die von Anfang an entwickelt wurde.
Das ist die beste Map.
Das haben die nicht einfach nur gesagt, weil typisch das Marketing-Stonks-Bullshit-Gelaber.
Nein, das haben die ernst gemeint.
Orbital ist ihre beste Map.
Obwohl ich sagen muss, mir gefällt Manifest auch besser.
Aber vom Inhalt her und vom Pollig-Stand her ist tatsächlich Orbital mit die beste Map.
Also ich meine, keine andere Map hat so eine Rakete und so einen Event und so was in der Richtung.
Also da sieht man wirklich, die haben da schon Zeit und Energie reingesteckt.
Und die haben uns zumindest keinen Mist erzählt.
Das ist wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt die beste Map gewesen.
Und trotzdem, obwohl, das muss ich jetzt auch vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal anmerken,
obwohl dieser Playtest nicht gut war, haben es trotzdem die englischen Content-Creator heftig gefeiert und rumgeschleimt.
Ich habe es ja bei diesem Event mitbekommen, meine Güte, wie da geschleimt wurde wieder.
Und es war so obvious, dass Sachen broken as fuck waren.
Aber es wurde rumgeschleimt as fuck.
Also wenn man sich in der Entwicklung auf das Feedback dieser Leute verlässt, dann ist man echt verloren.
Aber ich kann es ja verstehen.
Ich kann das ja nachvollziehen in gewisser Weise.
Wenn du da mit Dice irgendwie im gleichen Bett bist und dich mit denen gut stellst,
hast du vielleicht früher und Informationen früher oder generell Content früher,
equals mehr Views und equals mehr Geld.
Und die wollen außerdem wieder eingeladen werden.
Aber ich finde es halt trotzdem ein bisschen fragwürdig, ob das die beste Taktik ist,
da alles immer so mit Samthandschuhen anzufassen und nicht einfach mal klar zu sagen, was kacke ist und was nicht.
Hast du auch geschleimt?
Nee, ich habe in diesem Event im deutschen Discord geschrieben, das Wetter geht mir auf den Sack.
So sinngemäß.
Aber ich rede von englischsprachigen Content-Creator.
Von deutschsprachigen kann ich nichts sagen.
Die waren wahrscheinlich, doch ich glaube der Lost war eingeladen bei diesem internen Event.
Aber da weiß ich nicht.
Aber bei den englischsprachigen ist es halt besonders präsent gewesen, auch auf YouTube,
dass die sich total überschlagen haben bei allem möglichen.
Obwohl sie zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon wussten, in was für einem kacke Zustand das Game ist.
Also, wenn der Call of Duty Entwickler liegt, dass Battlefield in einem kacke Zustand ist,
dann ist ja schon irgendwas verkehrt, oder?
Vielleicht war das ein ehemaliger, wisst ihr was auch sein kann?
Dass das ein ehemaliger Battlefield-Entwickler war, der gewechselt ist oder so, keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite, die gehen halt auch zusammen Mittag essen.
Wobei, es ist Corona.
Ja, aber die haben bestimmt auch Kontakt.
Warum nicht?
Aber es ist auch der Zeitpunkt, in dem Insiders, auch ich, gesagt haben, dass sowohl die Beta des Spiels als auch der letzte Launch des Spiels belästigt werden.
Im Moment war nicht ganz klar, wie lange das belästigt werden wird.
Ernsthaft mal, Leute, dem Spiel hätten sie vorneweg eine Jahrzeit geben müssen und ich als Oldschool-Hardcore-Battlefield-Fan, ich hätte lieber noch ein Jahr oder meinetwegen auch eineinhalb oder zwei Jahre auf das Spiel gewartet, wenn es ein geiles Game geworden wäre.
Hätte ich überhaupt kein Problem gehabt, als statt das mit dem, wie wir es jetzt haben.
Läuft der Paid Public Beta-Test eigentlich noch?
Ja, ist immer noch jeden Tag ab.
Vor ein paar Stunden wurde klar, dass das Delay nur eine Woche sein würde, statt Monate, in denen einige der Entwickler des Spiels wollten, dass das Spiel in einem besseren Zustand werden würde.
Der Delay wurde eigentlich auf die englische Seite des Spiels gesetzt, ich bin nicht ganz sicher auf die Details davon, aber die englische Sache, die auf der Rückseite des Spiels gesetzt werden musste, konnte nicht in den Zeitraum der Release-Date befinden, die das Studio gegeben hat.
Stattdessen gab es noch ein paar Wochen, in denen die Leute krass verarscht wurden, war die Geschichte, wie alt das Beta-Build ist.
Das hat auch wieder die Leute komplett unvorbereitet getroffen, weil die meisten Leute überhaupt keine Ahnung von sowas haben. Wie gesagt, ich habe keine großartige Ahnung von Game-Entwicklung, aber ich habe eine Ahnung von Source-Control bzw. Git und wie man Repos und Software-Projekte handelt aus dieser Sicht.
Und selbstverständlich hat der Tag, wann da einer auf den Compile-Button gedrückt hat, nichts damit zu tun, also in diesem Beta-Build, nichts damit zu tun, welcher Source-Code da eigentlich drin ist.
Das war ja auch wieder Reddit und Twitter-Unterhaltung der Ahnungslosen an der Stelle, das war ganz schrecklich.
Zumindest haben sie im Endeffekt Scheiße erzählt, so von wegen, das Bild ist nicht alt, das Bild ist doch alt, und wie, und dann doch nicht so richtig.
Und natürlich wurde das Spiel im November ausgeliefert, das ist das Spiel, das wir alle spielen oder nicht spielen, in diesem Moment.
Die haben den Base-Jump gehabt, die haben einige Punkte drin gehabt in ihren Trailern, die explizit auf so diese Old-School-Battlefield-Sachen angesprochen wurden.
Und da bin ich ihnen wirklich böse drum, dass man das so gebadet quasi hat.
Das C4-Quad, ja, da war jede Menge Sachen in der Richtung, man hat die Veteranen gezielt gebadet, dass sie sich den Kram kaufen, mit Sachen, die eigentlich so, man kann nicht sagen, nicht drin sind, aber dieser Base-Jump, wer von euch hat den Base-Jump denn überhaupt schon mal gesehen wirklich in Battlefield 2042?
Ja, das ist aber Management-Fail-Versagen.
Ja, das muss man halt einfach machen, muss man halt sagen, okay Leute, das Ding ist noch nicht so weit, wir müssen es halt verschieben. Klar ist das vielleicht ein bisschen bitter für die Stonks und fürs Geld, aber das bessere Game kommt dann im Endeffekt nur so bei rum.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, spätestens bei der Beta war ich mir da echt nicht mehr so sicher, ob da was Gescheites rauskommt. Zumindest ich kann es jetzt auch verstehen nach dem Video, warum trotzdem viele, die bei DICE gearbeitet hatten, wenn man mal so oft Twitter rumguckt, warum die stolz sind auf dieses Game.
Ich kann das schon nachvollziehen in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Ich meine, das Game mag zwar nicht gut sein, was da am Endeffekt rausgekommen ist, aber ich denke schon, dass man stolz darauf sein kann, dass man das unter diesen Bedingungen überhaupt hinbekommen hat. Dass es natürlich der richtige Shitfest bei rausgekommen ist, gut, das ist was anderes.
QA-Testing, was ist das denn? Braucht man nicht.
Das frage ich mich auch. Na ja, oder aber, oder aber, es ist so wie ich gesagt habe, die Gamechangers, vor allem im englischsprachigen Bereich, die wurden befragt und haben einfach die krasse Schleimaction gemacht, so nach dem Motto DICE, you have made the best game ever.
Und da hat's DICE, genau, ihr Sieger, kein Problem.
Sie müssen vor allem ihre Entwickler bzw. ihre Designer lassen und nicht alle drei Monate die Ideen und Richtungen ändern.
Und ich glaube, wenn sie in der richtigen Art und Weise gemacht wurden, hätten sie auch die Revenu-Targeten getroffen, um die Spiele zu profitieren.
EA hat bereits gesehen, dass die Innovation mit Apex Legends erfolgreich war, aber leider sieht sich die Zukunft von Battlefield an dieser Zeit in den Füßen nach.
Die nächste Battlefield-Titel ist Scope to be a Hero-Shooter. Wir haben den Entwicklern nicht gesagt, dass das Spiel nicht mit Armys kämpft, sondern nur Bands von Spezialisten kämpfen.
Das ist keine Innovation, das ist nur eine Kopie der Konpetition.
Das Battlefield-Universum, das EA so hoch spricht, ist nichts mehr, als um die Spezialisten in den Füßen zu geben, und obwohl das Battle Royale nicht in den nächsten sechs Monaten in den Füßen sein wird, ist es definitiv geplant, das Battlefield-Universum in der nächsten Zukunft zu kommen.
Obwohl ich denke, es ist sicher zu sagen, dass Battlefield 2042 einen zerstörbaren Launch hatte, gibt es noch ein paar Positiven, die man von der Launch nehmen kann. Ich sehe mit meinen eigenen Augen die sehr harte Arbeit und Dedikation, die die Entwicklern in die Battlefield 2042 machen.
Das Battlefield-Universum, das EA so hoch spricht, ist nichts mehr, als um die Spezialisten in den Füßen zu geben, und obwohl das Battlefield-Universum in die Battlefield-Universum zu kommen.
Obwohl ich denke, es ist sicher zu sagen, dass die Entwicklern in die Battlefield-Universum, die die Battlefield-Universum in die Battlefield-Universum geben, sich schon schon einig sind, dass die Community nicht glücklich ist.
aber es ist sehr gut zu sehen, dass die DICE hinter den Szenen die Community Feedback hören und natürlich alle Bugzeuge im Spiel fixieren.
Ich denke, wenn wir als Community zusammenkommen, die Bugzeuge zu berichten und konstruktiv Feedback geben,
denke ich, dass Battlefield 2042 in einigen Monaten eine gute Battlefield-Experience sein wird.
Es gibt noch viele Bits und Bobs von Informationen, die wir mit Battlefield 2042 sprechen,
und natürlich werde ich Sie mit allen Informationen in Bezug auf nicht nur Battlefield 2042, aber auch auf die Zukunft der Battlefield-Franchise halten.
Am Ende dieses Videos wollte ich auch alle von euch bedanken, für das Zuschauen von diesem Video.
Dogtags! Dogtags war auch ein Ding, wo sie alte Veteranen gebaitet haben im Trailer.
Ich danke euch für die Unterstützung, was ich tue.
Und auch, wenn ihr meinen amerikanischen Kandy-Business, KandyCrate, gerne anschauen wollt, um euch ein paar amerikanische Sweets zu holen und auch, um ein bisschen Spaß zu haben, was ich mache,
mit den Beratungen von all diesen Beratungen.
Wir können uns alle eine Runde amerikanische Sweets kaufen.
Aber natürlich, wenn ihr irgendwo anders lebt, schreibt mir einfach eine DM auf Twitter und wir werden sehen, was wir da auch machen können.
Aber egal, Leute, das war es für dieses Video.
Ich bin Tom Henderson und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video.
Also, das Beste, was die Amis zu bieten haben, was Süßigkeiten angeht, sind Erdnussbutter.
So Schokoladendinger mit Erdnussbutter.
Das ist das Kokonaigste.
Also, ich kenne nichts, was mehr irgendwie Pepofett-Kokona ist, wie Erdnussbutter in Schokolade drin.
Haben die sowas hier?
Search.
Ja, wo ist denn hier die Produktübersicht?
Was ist für eine Kackseite?
Checkt ihr, wo die Produktübersicht ist?
Ach so, das ist so eine random.
Das ist so eine random.
Ah nee, hier, hier.
Okay, da ist nichts dabei, was ich...
Hier, das meine ich, Leute.
Erdnussbutter, Schokolade und viel Zucker noch dabei.
Das ist so krass Kokona Pepofett, mehr geht nicht.
Das, wer, wer, kannst du das...
Also, ich glaube, Ounces.
1,4 Ounces.
Alter, was für Freedom-Units, 39 Gramm, okay.
Was meint ihr, wie viel Kalorien hat so ein Ding?
Das steht da erst gar nicht dabei, oder?
Warum auch?
Sowas wird da nicht dabei geschrieben.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich drei Pizzas essen dafür.
So.
Ich weiß, dass es die auch in Deutschland zu kaufen gibt.
Deswegen kenne ich die ja.
Die sind wirklich heftig.
Wir gucken uns jetzt nochmal das GameStar-Review von der Witcher-Serie an.
Ich bin echt gespannt, ob sich das lohnt, das zu schauen.
Aber Leute, vorher, ich muss echt mal ganz schnell eine Runde pinkeln.
Afk kurz.
Okay.
So.
Ich bin jetzt wieder in Deutschland.
Hast du die Spiele gespielt?
Ja, alle.
Alle Witcher-Spiele.
Sogar das erste Witcher-Game.
Wo es diese komischen drei Attack-Modi gab, die sehr merkwürdig waren.
Das zweite habe ich aber nie durchgespielt.
So.
Dann schauen wir uns mal an.
Von wem wissen das Video?
Ah, Maurice.
Da wissen wir noch mal einer, der Ahnung hat.
Okay, war es gut.
Okay, ich bin jetzt wieder in Deutschland.
Das ist natürlich eine dreiste Lüge.
Ich könnte euch wahrscheinlich stundenlang über Witcher Season 2 zulabern.
Aber das will auch niemand.
Also versuchen wir es hier auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Ich habe die ersten sechs von insgesamt acht Folgen der Staffel 2.
Für diese Kritik vorab sehen dürfen.
Das heißt, das ist noch kein komplettes Fazit.
Aber nach drei Viertel der Staffel.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es nicht so viele Logik und so viele unerklärten Dinge gibt wie in Season 1.
In Season 1 gab es beispielsweise sehr viele Dinge, wo man sich so gefragt hat.
Hm, merkwürdig, zum Beispiel eine der Sachen, die mir noch einfällt, ist, dass der der fragt mich nicht, wie der hieß da.
Keine Ahnung, der Obertruide von den Defendern am Anfang, dass der später in der Serie einfach Geralt rumteleportieren kann.
Und am Anfang aber bei der Defense in der Festung sitzt und niemand rumteleportiert.
Warum nicht?
Wenn ich so einen krassen Teleport Dude habe und meine Festung wird überrannt, warum teleportiere ich mich dann nicht weg?
Das mag sein, dass das alles irgendwelche super High IQ Erklärungen hat.
Ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Sondern hat einfach gedacht, das passt so jetzt am besten.
Das sind so Dinge, wo ich mir denke, das musst du doch gescheit erklären.
Das passt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Und ich bin eher allergisch, wenn so offensichtliche Dinge drin sind, wo man sich denkt,
Alter, glauben die, dass die Zuschauer so bescheuert sind, dass es keiner mitbekommt?
Man kann sich da sicherlich einiges zusammen, war auf Cool Down, man kann sich da sicherlich einiges zusammenreimen.
Aber das ist Aufgabe der Ersteller, dass man das zumindest so weit umschrieben bekommt, dass man eine sinnvoll für sich schlüssige Erklärung hat.
Naja.
Ich will euch hier nicht erzählen Details über die Story.
Das hier ist eine Spoiler-freie Kritik.
Ihr müsst euch also keine Sorgen machen, dass ich euch irgendwie im Detail verrate, wie es weitergeht.
Ich will euch hier nur verraten, ob die Story was taugt.
Und es ist eine sehr andere Story als Staffel 1.
Ich hoffe, dass sie was taugt, weil ich fand die Story in der ersten Staffel nicht wirklich...
Klar, das war zwar mehr oder weniger so episodenmäßig, aber auch nicht so wirklich super nachvollziehbar.
Was ja auch zu erwarten war.
Denn Staffel 1 basierte noch auf den Hexer-Kurz-Geschichten und war damit recht episodisch, während Staffel 2 nun damit anfängt die Haupt-Romantik.
Was ich auch sehr merkwürdig fand in Staffel 1, muss ich jetzt einfach mal sagen.
Du hattest...
Also am Ende haben sich ja Geralt und Ciri im Wald getroffen.
So zum ersten Mal so richtig real-life wieder.
Du hattest überhaupt keine History mit diesen beiden Charakters zusammen.
Ja, Spoiler, Alter, Ende Season 1. Was wollt ihr denn jetzt?
Und du hast...
Die kannten sich gar nicht richtig vorher.
Und da sind die sich dann so quasi in die Arme gefallen, so nach dem Motto, als hätten die jetzt schon, keine Ahnung,
fünf Jahre lang super krassen Stellstar zusammen gemacht in der Welt.
Das fand ich auch nicht gut.
Und das bedeutet, dass die Handlung deutlich geradliniger auswählt.
Ja, das ist schon mal gut.
Und das ist in meinen Augen auch eine klare Verbesserung.
Staffel 1 hatte, finde ich, durchaus ein Problem damit, dass es mehrere Handlungsstränge gab,
die lange Zeit gar nicht so wirklich zueinander fanden und auch recht erratisch in der Zeit herumsprangen.
Witcher 2, Staffel 2 hat immer noch sehr viele unterschiedliche Handlungsstränge.
Es ist nicht unbedingt eine simplere Geschichte, die jetzt erzählt wird.
Es gibt immer noch auf der einen Seite Geralt, der eigentlich nur tun will, was für Ciri am besten ist,
während sich...
Sowas finde ich ja in Fantasy-Filmen oder generell auch in Filmen, die oder Serien, die im Mittelalter spielen.
Finde ich sowas ja auch immer witzig.
Es gibt immer noch auf...
Wenn die dann so komische Moves machen, warum muss der jetzt...
Auf der einen Seite Geralt, der eigentlich...
Warum muss der das Ding nach hinten erstechen?
Warum kann er sich nicht umdrehen und einfach mit dem Schwert nach vorne stechen?
But why?
Warum sollte man Moves machen, die einen umbringen würden?
... was für Ciri am besten ist, während sich im Hintergrund...
Der ist einfach so gelangweilt von dem Monster.
Der denkt sich, alter, die Monster sind eh kein Match für mich.
Ich mach das jetzt mit Style-Rücklingsblatt.
... verschiedensten politischen Intrigen rund um den Krieg gegen Nilfgaard entspinnen,
aber all diese Dinge passieren jetzt zum einen synchron miteinander.
Gib mir HXB, ja.
Und zum anderen hängen sie jetzt auch deutlich klarer und erkennbarer miteinander zusammen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Was die Geschichte zum einen leichter zu verfolgen macht, gerade für Leute, die die Bücher nicht kennen.
Zum anderen aber auch einfach, finde ich, besser zum Anschauen.
Also eine gewisse Vereinfachung in diesem Sinne ist ja nicht immer was Schlechtes.
Und wie gesagt, es ist immer noch keine simple oder dumme Handlung.
Sie ist nur etwas geradliniger.
Was sie aber nicht ist, und das hat mich etwas überrascht, ist deswegen sonderlich schneller.
Im Gegenteil, sie ist tatsächlich immer noch recht gemächlich.
Und auch das hätte man sich eigentlich denken können.
Dude, Special Effects.
Auch die Witcher-Bücher, bei allen Stärken, die sie haben,
sind nicht unbedingt in halbstbrecherischem Tempo erzählt
und lassen sich manchmal sogar etwas zu viel Zeit sich in irgendwelchen Nebenergüssen zu ergehen,
statt wirklich spannend die Handlung voranzutreiben.
Und das macht auch Witcher Season 2.
Es wird immer noch sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht, ominöse Mysterien im Hintergrund aufzubauen.
Wir sind immer noch nicht an dem Punkt...
Das sieht original aus wie das Schwert aus den Games.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie büchermäßig nach erfunden ist,
aber das ist original ein Schwert aus dem Game.
Wir sind immer noch nicht an dem Punkt, wo sehr viel, ich sag mal, Payoff für diese Mysterien stattfindet.
Was auch wieder ein wenig sich logisch aus der Struktur des Ganzen ergibt,
dass wir hier eigentlich einen zweiten Anfang hier haben.
Wir hatten erst den Anfang der Kurzgeschichtensammlungen
und dann eben eine Staffel 1, die sich durch diese Kurzgeschichten hangelte.
Übrigens, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das mal aufgefallen ist,
der Hintergrund ist nicht CGI hier.
Der Hintergrund ist Low Budget, der Hintergrund ist Leinwände.
Schaut mal genau hin.
Das ist gemalte Leinwandhintergrund.
Da war kein Budget mehr da.
CGI hat zu viel für das Monster gefressen.
Hier sieht man es gut.
Das ist quasi einfach nur eine Leinwand, gemalt mit Bäumen drauf.
Und jetzt haben wir Staffel 2, die eigentlich ja den Anfang der Romanserie darstellt.
Das heißt, wo Staffel 1 recht viel Zeit mit Aufbau verbracht hat, was die Figuren und die Welt angeht,
verbringt Staffel 2 immer noch sehr viel Zeit mit Aufbau, was den eigentlichen übergreifenden Plot angeht.
Und deswegen ist sie im Negativen nicht immer so spannend, wie man das vielleicht gerne hätte
und braucht ziemlich lange, bis sie wirklich mal an den Punkt kommt, wo die Handlung wirklich Fahrt aufnimmt
und die Figuren nicht mehr nur einfach auf Dinge reagieren, die ihnen passieren durch ominöse höhere Gewalt,
sondern tatsächlich anfangen von sich aus Ziele zu verfolgen und zu agieren, statt Spielball zu sein.
Der Vorteil dieser ganzen etwas gemächlicheren Geschwindigkeit ist aber,
dass sich Staffel 2 wie auch Staffel 1 schon schön viel Zeit für Charaktermomente nimmt.
Zum Glück sind es die gleichen Schauspieler.
Das finde ich immer richtig painstjemp, wenn nach einem Staffelwechsel irgendwo die Leute anders aussehen.
Sehr, sehr gut gefallen, sogar besser als in der ersten Staffel.
Über Geralt, über Henry Cavill, müssen wir eigentlich gar nicht mehr groß reden.
Er ist einfach der perfekte Geralt, das weiß jeder.
Ich finde den wirklich, das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht am Anfang.
Ich hatte ja so Superman im Kopf, als sie den angekündigt haben.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, das passt ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich muss sagen, das ist wirklich gut.
Ich war jetzt kein großer Fan der ersten Witcher Staffel, aber den fand ich wirklich gut.
Was Ciri wurde gewechselt, das ist doch immer noch die gleiche.
Also die sah eben sehr, sehr ähnlich zu Ciri aus der ersten Staffel aus.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Nee, aber das war echt für mich so eines der Highlights.
Das war echt gut.
...gesehen hat und er ist es in Staffel 2 ebenso.
Er schafft es weiterhin wunderbar.
Außer, außer, dass er immer...
Da gibt es ja schon so eine Compilation auf YouTube auch,
dass Geralt in der ersten Witcher Staffel immer, jeden zweiter Satz war ja Fuck.
Da hat er gefühlt laufen Fuck gesagt, genau Fuck.
Das ist definitiv noch die gleiche aus der ersten Staffel.
Weil Leute, die das nicht gesehen haben, das ist übrigens Triss. Moment.
Das ist übrigens Triss.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie Triss in den Büchern aussieht.
Sieht zumindest nicht aus wie in den Games.
WTF, warum kein Redhead? Ja ich wäre auch dafür, man hätte Allotricks als Triss casten müssen, beste.
Shani, beste, ja, sehe ich auch so.
Das schwächste Glied von den drei Hauptfiguren für mich in der ersten Staffel war tatsächlich Freya Allen als Ciri.
Das lag aber auch wieder vor allem an der Storyline, die die Figur hatte,
weil sie einfach noch nicht die Ciri war, die gerade wir als Spielefans vielleicht auch kennen,
sondern sehr am Anfang stand und halt eigentlich weitgehend die verschreckte Prinzessin spielen musste,
die ständig vor allem nur davon rennt.
In Staffel 2 sehen wir jetzt den Anfang zur Entwicklung der Ciri, die wir alle cool finden aus den späteren Büchern und den Spielen.
Und da merkt man, dass auch die Schauspielerin mit ihrer Figur auftaucht und weniger steif wird und mehr Facetten zeigen kann.
Und das ebenfalls cool macht, auch wenn ich immer noch fand, dass sie die Rolle nicht ganz so sich komplett zu eigen macht
und so rockt wie zum Beispiel Henry Cavill als Geralt, der für mich ab jetzt...
Wann ist eigentlich Release?
Wann kommen wir?
Witcher Season 2 Release.
17, 5 Tage, okay.
...Geralt ist. So weit ist die Serie in Ciri noch nicht.
Und das liegt für mich auch daran, dass ihre Beziehung zu Geralt noch nicht 100% authentisch...
Ja gut, wie auch.
Das ist, by the way, das Ende von Season 1, was ich euch angeblich gerade gespoilert hab, ja.
Das wie auch. Die hatten ja überhaupt keinerlei, kaum Zeit zusammen in Staffel 1.
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass die so tun, als kennen die sich schon 50 Jahre.
...überkommt, was auch daran liegt, dass die Serie hier einige Änderungen gegenüber den Büchern gemacht hat
und Ciri, bei ihrem ersten Aufeinandertreffen mit Geralt, erstens älter ist, als sie in den Büchern war
und zum anderen war das in den Büchern gar nicht das allererste Treffen.
Genau.
Sie hatten sich davor schon mal gesehen, es gab auch von Ciri...
Siehst du, deswegen, das ist natürlich dann blöd, wenn man das ändert, weil so ergibt das einfach keinen Sinn.
...deutlich mehr Wunsch, Geralt zu finden und sich mit ihm eine Familie zu werden, als in der Serie.
Nun ist das tatsächlich aber auch eine schwer glaubwürdig rüberzubringende Geschichte,
dass zwei Menschen, die sich kaum kennen, durch das Schicksal und Prophezeiungen zusammengebracht werden
und dann super toll Vater und Tochter sind, das braucht sehr viel Finesse, um das glaubwürdig zu vermitteln
und das schafft Staffel 2 nur teilweise in meinen Augen.
Es gibt Momente, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, die Serie ist jetzt schon an dem Punkt, wo ich denken soll,
die sind schon eine tolle Familie, aber ich fühle es als Zuschauer noch nicht so sehr.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar noch weniger fühlen, wenn ich nicht Buch- und Spielkenner wäre,
der die beiden Figuren schon kennt.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe alle Spiele gespielt und das Einzige, was ich von den Büchern kenne,
ist die Hörbuchversion von einem der Kurzgeschichten-Bände.
Also wirklich Plan von der eigentlichen Witcher-Story in den Büchern habe ich nicht.
Auf welche innige Beziehung das mal hinausläuft, ich bringe das ja schon ein bisschen mit.
Habe ich auch nicht vor.
Ich will, dass es an diesen Punkt kommt und die Staffel 2 fängt im späteren Verlauf an,
das besser rüber zu bringen und kommt an diesen Punkt schrittweise, langsam,
aber es fühlt sich noch nicht immer wahrhaftig an.
Jetzt hat er aber hier hart rumphilosophiert.
Und das ist schade, weil diese Beziehung ja so wichtig für die Handlung von The Witcher ist,
aber sie stützt sich schon noch sehr stark auf, es ist halt Schicksal und so
und man fühlt es noch nicht ganz so sehr aus den Charakteren heraus.
Und das ist nicht die einzige Änderung, die Staffel 2 gegenüber den Büchern vornimmt.
Und ich war ehrlich gesagt richtig überrascht, wie unglaublich viel sie umdichtet oder neu erfindet.
Das ist meistens keine allzu gute Sache.
Also ich habe bei Game of Thrones, ich kenne auch nicht die Bücher,
aber ich habe nur geguckt bis Staffel 4 war das, glaube ich.
Und Staffel 4 war dann, lustigerweise habe ich im Internet gelesen,
war dann quasi die Staffel, wo es langsam anfing, dass man sich so von den Büchern wegbewegt hat,
weil halt eben keine neuen Bücher nachgekommen sind
und viele Storys, die aus den Büchern schon durch waren.
Und ich denke mal, der Grund war mit,
also das war wohl mit eines der Gründe, warum es mir danach nicht mehr gefallen hat.
Ich habe dann auch aufgehört zu gucken.
Außerdem war, ich kann bis heute nicht verstehen, warum Game of Thrones so ein wahnsinniger Erfolg war.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand das sicherlich nicht schlecht, gerade die ersten drei Staffeln,
aber das war schon mega mega lahmarschig teilweise.
Aber gut, das ist sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Fast kaum eine Szene, die wirklich eins zu eins so im Buch stattfindet.
Und das war als Hardcore-Fan von Buch und Spiel ziemlich irritierend,
weil ich ständig mir dachte, Moment, das war doch im Buch nicht so, oder?
Nee, bin ich mir recht sicher, dass das nicht so war.
Ich habe ständig nach jeder Folge Fan-Wiggis gegoogelt, weil ich mir selber nicht mehr sicher war.
Dann erinnere ich mich jetzt falsch, aber nee, das war doch nicht so, oder?
Und die Figur hier gab es doch überhaupt nicht in den Büchern, und warum ist der jetzt da?
Und solche Momente hatte ich ständig.
Die Sache ist aber, wenn man mal etwas loslässt und einen Schritt zurücktritt,
merkt man, so groß die Änderungen auch sind,
so wenig verwässern sie überraschenderweise den Kern der Geschichte,
weil das Herz unberührt bleibt, es ist im Kern die gleiche grundlegende Geschichte
von einer Familie aus Menschen, die versucht sich zu finden
und irgendwie ihren Weg zu gehen in einer immer mehr vom Chaos gezeichneten Welt.
Es ist immer noch die Geschichte der Invasion von Nilfgaard gegen den Noren,
es ist immer noch die Geschichte von Rassismus gegen...
Madminister, hast du recht, aber ich gucke trotzdem die Videos von Maruis echt gern.
Es ist im Kern immer noch The Witcher, nur die einzelnen Schritte sind teilweise sehr anders,
aber nicht in den Punkten, wo es wirklich zählt, weitgehend.
Ey Leute, das CGI in dieser Folge aus der ersten Staffel war so schlecht, Alter.
Das ist das, wo es diesen Golddrache gab, das war so, das war so mies.
Das CGI, Alter, das war Payne's Champ, da war kein Budget mehr übrig.
Einer meiner liebsten Fantasy Autoren, Brandon Sanderson, hat neulich auf Reddit einen Post verfasst,
wo er darüber geschrieben hat, dass er als Experiment mal zwei Drehbücher
für die Filmumsetzung von einem seiner Bücher von Mistborn geschrieben hat.
Eins, wo er versucht hat, möglichst nah am Original Text zu bleiben.
Und eins, wo er eigentlich alle Buchszene rausgeschmissen hat
und sich bei jeder aufs Neue gefragt hat, wenn ich die gleiche Geschichte erzählen wollen würde,
aber von Grund auf mich von der Frage leiten lassen würde,
was ist das Beste für einen möglichst guten Film, hätte ich diese Szene so geschrieben.
Und er hat gemeint, da kam dann auch etwas raus, was kaum noch Szenen mit dem Buch gemeinsam hatte,
aber die gleiche Seele auf bessere Weise auf den Bildschirm transportiert hat.
Das klingt nachvollziehbar.
Und damit hat er sich nicht auf The Witcher bezogen, das war eine Diskussion um die Wheel of Time Serie,
die ich tatsächlich nicht sonderlich toll fand.
Oh ne, hör mal auf, Wheel of Time hab ich auch nicht gelesen, aber ganz ehrlich,
was Amazon da fabriziert hat, ich konnt's mir nicht geben.
Aber ich fand es sehr anwendbar auf The Witcher Season 2, weil da ein sehr ähnliches Phänomen passiert in meinen Augen.
Hat jemand von euch, das die Serie geguckt und zufälligerweise die Bücher gelesen zu Wheel of Time?
Also wie gesagt, ich hab mich an der Serie versucht, ich fand's Payne's Champion, ich hoch 10 und die Bücher kenne ich nicht.
Aber wenn schon für jemanden, der die Bücher nicht kennt, das so grausam ist.
Die stimmungsvollsten Szenen, die ich am imposantesten fand, die am stimmungsvollsten waren, am coolsten waren,
waren Szenen, die absolut nicht im Buch waren.
Die teilweise überhaupt nichts mit irgendeinem Buchplot zu tun hatten, aber sie waren richtig gut.
Ich fand sie als Bereicherung für die Story cool.
Und sie bauen teilweise auch Aspekte aus, die zentral für die Bücher sind und jetzt einfach nur noch mehr betont werden,
wie zum Beispiel die Verfolgung der Elfen.
Das wird noch viel mehr in den Vordergrund gestellt und noch viel auch teilweise verstörender dargestellt, was die Geschichte aber nur stärker macht.
Das gilt aber nicht für den zweiten Aspekt, der ebenfalls noch mehr in den Vordergrund gestellt wird.
M312, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es ein Problem ist.
Und ich nenne es mal ganz böse magisches Geschwurbel.
Die Prophezeiung, dein Schicksal, das Ende der Welt, die Regeln der Magie,
seht dort im Wald diese mächtige Hexe, die es im Buch überhaupt nicht gab,
und bedenkt doch nur die Monolithen und die Sphärenkonjunktion und all diese Dinge.
Das ist in der Serie ebenfalls deutlich prägnanter und zum Teil fand ich es irritierend,
wie sie in meinen Augen manchmal ganze Storylines damit losgetreten haben,
dass sie irgendwelche neuen Regeln der Magie oder neue magische Phänomene aus dem Hut gezogen haben,
die im Buch überhaupt nicht vorhanden waren.
Ja, das ist ja beliebt.
Wenn dir nichts mehr einfällt, warum Figur von A nach C gehen soll über B, ja, Magic.
Hast du DLCs? Ja, alle.
Der erste Witcher 3 DLC, Leute. Es ist eines der besten Sachen, die ich je gespielt habe.
Finde ich.
Ist richtig, richtig nice.
Und gerade, um nicht zu verwessen...
Und was wir auch gewissen ist ja, dass alles, was schon etwas creepy ist,
noch mehr, noch schlimmer wird, wenn irgendeine Kinder das singen.
Wo auch immer.
Das macht.
Das sind Film und Game Scan, dass wenn irgendwas schon gruselig ist,
dann brauchst du noch irgendwelche creepy Kinder, die das dann auch von sich geben und dann geht's noch schlimmer.
...oder viel weniger wichtig waren und die in meinen Augen auch schon im Buch jetzt nicht die starke Seite der Story waren.
Obwohl es ja wichtig war und deswegen verstehe ich auch, warum sie in der Serie vielleicht das mehr erklären und den Vordergrund rücken wollen,
weil du brauchst es ja trotzdem, die ganze Geschichte um die Prophezeiung und Ciri's Blut und so, das brauchst du ja, um die Geschichte von The Witcher zu erzählen.
Und es war schon teilweise ein bisschen diffus in den Büchern und auch in den Spielen, was da jetzt eigentlich genau der Sinn der Sache ist.
Deswegen verstehe ich auch, warum sie es in der Serie jetzt mehr noch in den Vordergrund rücken.
Ich fand's aber ein bisschen zu viel an einigen Stellen und ich fand, man hätte da auch ein bisschen weniger draufsetzen können,
auf so sehr viel ominöse magische Mysterien, die eben zum Teil auch wirklich nicht sehr...
Manche Sachen sollte man erklären, ja, zum Beispiel warum ein Character in der einen Szene teleportieren kann und in der anderen nicht,
obwohl es in der anderen noch wichtiger gewesen wäre. Das sollte man in irgendeine sinnvolle Erklärung haben.
Aber manche Sachen ist nicht schlimm, weil man die ein bisschen mysteriös lässt.
Um Storypunkte zu erzwingen, das fand ich teilweise ein bisschen übertrieben.
Auch wenn es, wie bereits gesagt, einige richtig coole Szenen hervorbringt, die ich jetzt nicht spoilern will.
Ich denke, ihr werdet ein paar davon erkennen, die ich meine, wenn ihr die Serie dann selbst seht.
Es gibt wenige wirklich schlimme Brüche mit der Story. Also bei allen Änderungen bleibt die Seele für mich unverfälscht,
wenn sie so weitergeführt werden, die Story doch auf einer tieferen Ebene zu verfälschen.
Auch hier will ich jetzt eben nichts spoilern. Auch da werden euch ein paar während dem Schauen selbst auffallen.
Einen, den wir schon aus der Staffel 1 kennen, ist zum Beispiel, dass Nilfgaard,
dieses komplette Element des religiösen Fanatismus, noch mit dazu gedichtet wurde, was auch weiter ausgebaut wird hier.
Und das kann ja das ganze Wesen von Nilfgaard, einem sehr wichtigen Storypunkt, sehr verändern.
Es gibt noch deutlich größere Änderungen an der Story in der zweiten Staffel, die potenziell eine Lavine lostreten können.
Ja gut, da kann ich halt nichts zu sagen. Ich kenne die Vorlage nicht.
Ich glaube, dass das auch noch mal zu Brüchen führt, wo wir sagen werden als Buchfans,
okay, das ist jetzt mir zu viel, das ist Quatsch.
Weitgehend bis lang hält es sich im Rahmen für mich mit einer Ausnahme,
und das fand ich auch schon in der ersten Staffel ein Problem, nämlich der Charakter von Cahir,
dem meiner Meinung nach in der Serie massives Unrecht getan wird, weil er als komplettes Sackgesicht dargestellt wird.
Und das ist er ja im Buch überhaupt nicht und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der Serie in Cahir ist.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer auf welchem Buchstaffel 2 basiert, wahrscheinlich ist es eine Mischung aus mehreren.
Je noch mal zu dem Buch Cahir werden soll, und wenn das überhaupt nicht wird,
dann wäre das, finde ich, schon ein sehr harter Bruch, den ich auch kritisieren müsste.
Und in der zweiten Staffel gab es ein paar Momente, wo ich dachte, ah, da fangen sie jetzt an mit seiner Entwicklung zu dem Charakter, den wir kennen,
aber das werfen sie dann alles wieder über den Haufen, das ist irgendwie, und dann ist er doch wieder ein Sack.
Selbst wenn sie jetzt noch anfangen würden, ihn in eine andere Richtung zu entwickeln,
war er meiner Meinung nach schon zu sehr ein Sackgesicht, als dass ich ihm das noch abkaufen würde.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie sie diesen Charakter noch mal rumdrehen wollen.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Die müssen es halt, aber keine Ahnung, wie das noch klappen soll.
Was dafür Fans der Spiele umso mehr freuen dürfte, ist, dass bei allen Brüchen mit den Büchern,
Witcher Season 2, deutlich mehr Anleihen bei den Videospielen.
Ja, ihr wisst ja auch warum, weil das wahrscheinlich die Hardcore-Fans mittlerweile sind und es halt viel mehr davon gibt.
Ganz ehrlich, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass 95% der Leute, die heute überhaupt von der Existenz von The Witcher wissen,
das eben aus den Spielen tun und nicht aus den Büchern.
Wir wissen ja schon lange, dass Henry Cavill ein hoffnungsloser Nerd ist, nicht nur für Witcher,
sondern zum Beispiel auch für Warhammer und Total War, aber auch für The Witcher.
Und dass er zum Beispiel versucht hat, die Badeszene aus Season 1 mehr an die aus den Spielen ranzubringen,
was ich fantastisch finde.
Aber in Season 2 merkt man, offenbar sind jetzt noch mehr Gaming-Fans in der Crew
oder sie haben jetzt mehr Freiheit erhalten, das auch raushängen zu lassen.
Zum Beispiel Vesemir.
Okay, das sieht ihm wirklich ähnlich aus, ja.
Und ich finde das super. Vesemir ist fantastisch in der Serie.
Ich fand ihn richtig gut gespielt, gut umgesetzt, hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Aber eben für uns Spiele-Fans nochmal ein extra Bonus, dass er tatsächlich auch wie in den Spielen rüberkommt.
Die einzige Enttäuschung für Videospiel-Fans...
Ja, Triss ist immer noch nicht rothaarisch.
Das ist halt einfach nicht die Figur aus den Spielen.
Sie bringt nicht das gleiche Feuer rüber.
Sie sieht auch nicht so aus.
Es gibt ein paar Szenen, wo sie tatsächlich...
Sieht ein bisschen mehr jetzt danach aus.
Auch hier haben sie ein bisschen in die Richtung...
Ach, Moment!
Triss kriegt rote Haare jetzt, oder was?
Aha.
Und es gibt ein paar Szenen, wo sie eine Frisur wie in Witcher 3 hat.
Und lässig ist auch das Aussehen als Charakter natürlich erstmal nicht so wichtig.
Aber ich finde auch von der Darstellung der Rolle her sonst bringt sie einfach nicht die Power mit, die die Triss aus den Spielen hat.
Das kann man der Serie aber nicht wirklich angreifen, weil eigentlich haben die Spiele da den Fehler gemacht.
Weil Triss in den Büchern ist schlichtweg nicht so wichtig wie Triss in den Spielen.
Deswegen ist es in dem Fall...
Na gut, Triss ist ja nur in den Games...
Also ich gehe mal davon aus.
Die ist nur in den Games überhaupt ursprünglich reingekommen.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass im ersten Teil konntest du ja noch irgendwelche Karten sammeln von Mädels, die du als Geralt flachlegen konntest.
Und Triss war einfach nur aus schlagenden Argumente halber im Spiel ursprünglich.
Aber ich finde es extrem, dass sie das hier auch ein bisschen zurückfahren.
Persönlich hätte ich mir aber gewünscht, wenn ihr schon so viele Brüche mit den Büchern eh macht,
dass wäre einer, der ich euch total verziehen hätte, wenn Triss noch etwas wichtiger und cooler geworden wäre.
Da hätte ich null Probleme damit gehabt.
Ich finde das als Spielefan tatsächlich etwas schade, auch wenn ich es wie gesagt nicht objektiv kritisiere.
Es ist rein subjektiv etwas, was ich schade finde und wo ich glaube, was auch einige andere Leute schade finden werden.
Aber es wäre schön gewesen.
Am klarsten wird der Videospieleinfluss aber bei den Hexerzeichen.
Denn in mehreren Kämpfen werfen die Hexer mit Zeichen um sich, wie du das halt in Witcher 3 zum Beispiel machst.
Wie sie es aber nie in den Büchern machen, wenn in den Büchern die Hexerzeichen viel viel schwächer sind.
Aber es kommt zum Beispiel mehrfach das Schildzeichen Quenn zum Einsatz auf eine Art und Weise, die jeder Gamer sofort erkennt.
Ah ja, das ist doch mein... Wenn OP... Können ihr euch noch am Anfang erinnern, wo du quasi mit unendlich Leben haben konntest?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht immer noch geht. Wahrscheinlich geht das immer noch.
Du hattest einfach unendlich Leben, weil das noch dein Leben wieder aufgefüllt hat.
Das war das Noobbild in Witcher 3.
Den Arsch gerettet in den Spielen. Cool, dass Geralt es hier auch so benutzt.
Und das fand ich nett zu sehen, weil es auch... Es ist vielleicht ein Bruch mit den Büchern, aber es ist finde ich ein unwichtiger.
Erneut eben. Es verfälscht nichts an der Essenz der Geschichte und macht einfach die Kämpfe und die Hexer noch ein bisschen cooler.
Also das können sie von mir aus sehr gerne machen.
Überhaupt war die Action weitgehend gelungen.
Man merkt aber auch, dass sie bei den Kämpfen gegen Monster nicht ganz das Budget hatten, längere aufwändige Choreografien gegen ein komplettes CGI Monster zu machen.
Diese Kämpfe sind oft ein bisschen kürzer und du merkst eben, ok, da stößt eine Serie vielleicht an die Grenzen ihres Budgets.
Und ich hätte mir noch ein paar mehr Kämpfe einfach nur gegen Menschen gewünscht.
Wie zum Beispiel die Szene auf dem Marktplatz in Blaviken in Staffel 1.
Die eins der Highlights dieser Staffel war, obwohl eben keine Monster am Start waren, aber die Kampfchoreografie war so fantastisch.
Es gibt solche Szenen auch in Staffel 2.
Wenn auch wieder Hardcore unrealistisches rumgedrehe, aber gut, das ist halt Witcher Kampfstil, das lasse ich mir noch gefallen.
...gern noch mehr machen können, dafür waren die Monster richtig cool.
Also ich fand die waren richtig eindrucksvoll und ekelhaft designt.
Der Waldschrat zum Beispiel ist nochmal um einiges cooler als in den Spielen.
So ein richtig bizarres Baum-Bondage Monster und nicht mal das widerlichste Monster.
Es gibt noch einige deutlich Schlimmere.
Das haben sie sehr gut gemacht und allgemein fand ich die Serie handwerklich sehr gut gemacht.
Also Kostümdesign, wie gesagt Nilfgaard Rüstungen tauchen endlich was.
Damit habe ich jetzt am Kostümdesign auch nichts mehr auszusetzen.
Optische Effekte halten sich ein bisschen in Grenzen aufgrund von Serienbudget.
Man merkt das ab und an, dass sie sich zurückhalten mussten, aber wo sie eingesetzt werden sind sie cool.
Das Monster CDI sieht weitgehend gut aus.
Kaer Morhen zum Beispiel richtig cool designt.
Also der Mittelalter Fantasy Fan hat durchaus auch ein bisschen Anleihen vom Game.
Leute jetzt eine Runde Quent, wie sieht es aus?
Auf seine Kosten, auch was die Musik angeht, die auch wieder sehr sehr stimmungsvoll war.
Und natürlich gibt es auch wieder Neues von Rittersporn.
Auch wenn ihm in meinen Ohren, nicht Augen, jetzt wollte ich Augen sagen, aber es sind ja Ohren.
Diesmal nicht so ein Ohrwurm geglückt ist wie TossaCoin.
Das wäre aber auch schwer gewesen.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was ich der Staffel vorwerfe.
Sie haben es sogar versucht und es ist coole Musik bei rausgekommen, die sicher viele Fans auch gerne hören werden.
Ich glaube ganz so viral wird aus dieser Staffel nichts gehen.
Es sei denn in den letzten zwei Folgen, die ich noch nicht gesehen habe, kommt noch was.
Das kann gut sein, aber trotzdem war ich musikalisch zufrieden.
Es ist ja auch okay, wenn es nicht nochmal gleich so ein Phänomen wird wie dieser Song.
Auch wenn es damals... Der Song war das beste aus Staffel 1.
Ansonsten fand ich das ehrlich gesagt zum größten Teil sehr mittelmäßig, aber das Song war wirklich nice.
Die erste Staffel habe ich ja vorab gesehen und ich hatte diesen Ohrwurm dann schon, bevor er an die Öffentlichkeit, sage ich mal, gelangt.
Es war dann sehr lustig zu sehen, wie dieser Song sich wie ein Lauffeuer verbreitet.
Da habe ich nur so, ja ja, das kann ich gut verstehen. Ich habe schon seit zwei Wochen diesen Ohrwurm.
Vielleicht passiert das hier auch, vielleicht lege ich falsch, sobald die Staffel draußen ist, wird man sehen müssen.
Aber was ist jetzt das Fazit? Es ist durchwachsen, sage ich mal.
Ich fand, The Witcher Season 2 hat Probleme mit seiner Geschichte.
Sie ist ein wenig arg langsam und fühlt sich lange Zeit zierloser an als eine Season 2 sein sollte, in meinen Augen.
Aber sie hat mir trotzdem unterm Strich sehr viel Spaß gemacht, weil ich mit diesen Figuren und in dieser Welt einfach sehr gerne Zeit verbringe.
Und die Serie immer noch sehr stark davon getragen wird, dass sie das Herz von The Witcher, die allerwichtigsten Sachen,
wie zum Beispiel eine gute Darstellung von Geralt, einfach richtig, richtig gut macht.
Und das trägt einen auch darüber hinweg, dass es vielleicht mal ein bisschen langsam vorangeht.
Und das wird auch überhaupt nicht davon verwässert überraschenderweise, dass eben eigentlich sehr, sehr viel geändert wird an der Geschichte,
weil viele dieser Änderungen überraschend gut funktionieren und das Herz der Story...
Also wenn ich Maurice richtig verstehe, ist das immer noch ziemlich mittelmäßig, wenn es aber auch einige gute Momente hat.
Oder wie würdet ihr das interpretieren?
Oder sogar besser hervorbringen. Man wird aber sehen müssen, wie das weitergeht.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, wo die Serie vorsichtig sein muss, nicht zu sehr vom Kurs abzukommen.
Und sie muss jetzt finde ich schon allmählich mal mehr Fahrt aufnehmen, weil wir hatten jetzt zwei Seasons Aufbau.
Jetzt kann auch mal ein bisschen Fahrt kommen. Das zeichnet sich auch ab gegen Ende von Season 2.
Und wer weiß, was in diesen zwei Folgen noch kommt, die ich noch nicht gesehen habe.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall weiter dranbleiben. Bei aller Kritik hatte ich, wie gesagt, richtig Spaß mit der Staffel.
Ich mag die Figuren, ich mag die Schauspieler, ich mag die Welt, ich mag die Darstellung, ich mag die Geschichte.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt zu sehen, wie es weitergeht. Und das ist doch unter anderem ein positives Fazit.
Auch wenn es nicht die 10 von 10 vielleicht ist, die ich am Anfang für die Nilfgaarder Rüstung...
Ich finde es immer noch krass, wie sehr Maurice abgenommen hat.
...vergeben habe. Es ist irgendwo...
Vergleich von vor so 2, 3 Jahren.
...würde ich sagen, wenn man Serien so bewerten muss. Und das ist ja keineswegs schlecht.
Also 7 von 10 ist fast schon hart. Also wie gesagt, mir hat es gut gefallen, obwohl ich auch noch Dinge auszusetzen habe...
Okay, sagen wir mal relativ mittelmäßig.
Vielleicht solltet ihr auch gar nicht so sehr auf...
Alles klar, Maurice. Ich guck's mir auf jeden Fall an.
Aber wie gesagt, ich fand die erste Staffel auch so... Naja.
Oh, ich hab Hunger.
Das haben wir schon geguckt. Gucken wir jetzt nicht. Gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, gucken wir jetzt auch nicht.
Äh, gucken wir jetzt... Was kann Lego break an Aluminiumbeam?
Okay, das ist kurz. Das muss ich mir jetzt noch angucken.
Lass mich raten. Das funktioniert. Aber erst, nachdem er wieder irgendwie 2 km hohen Turm gebaut hat, der dann mit einer Übersetzung von 30.000 zu 1 irgendwie an diesem Ding dreht.
Ich wollte grad sagen, wenn er Stahl durchgekriegt hat, sollte er Aluminium doch auch kriegen, aber das ist dicker.
Gib ihm.
Pause-Champ.
Sekunde, Leute, ich lass einfach mal die Musik dabei an.
Die passt eigentlich ganz gut dazu.
Sack, Sack.
Das tut ja schon weh beim Zugucken.
Dass ist doch der... Das sadly-st husband-Kriterium.
Das tut ja schon weh beim zugucken.
Das ist doch, das ist doch ne Ecke ab am Ende, oder?
Damaged.
Das tut ja schon wirklich weh.
Nicht so Koggas würde ich sagen.
Was heißt denn Crank auf deutsch Hebel oder irgendwie sowas müsste das heißen, hä?
Kurbel, ah Kurbel.
Alter, dieses Geräusch, das ist schon Pains Cem.
Aber es biegt sich schon ein bisschen, oder?
Hat sich ein bisschen, ne.
Das Geräusch ist schon Pains Cem, Alter.
Das bricht doch hier unten gleich wieder ab.
Na, na?
Ist das gebogen?
Ne, nix gebogen.
Ich könnte mir fast vorstellen, dass es schwierig wird, so fest einzuquetschen, dass sie nicht
bewegt.
Ich mein, man könnte jetzt natürlich Trick 17 machen und das mehrfach schnell hoch und
runter fahren, wobei so schnell wirst du das nicht hinkriegen.
Ich wollt grad sagen, wenn du das mehrfach schnell hoch und runter fährst, dann würde
das warm werden und einfacher, aber das wird, das Lego soll ich nicht mitmachen.
Oh, oh, oh, Postchamp, Postchamp.
Bisschen gebogen ist es.
Geh mit größerer Übersetzung, jawoll.
Das Ziel, das zu biegen, ich glaub, das Ziel ist es, das durchzudrehen.
Also ja, so weit zu biegen, dass es durchbricht.
Mal gucken, aber es ist schon mal, es geht schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Oh, jetzt kommt aber Big Brain, okay, jetzt hat er aber aufgerüstet, Leute.
Jetzt hat er, jetzt hat er aufgerüstet, Five-Hat-Time.
Dann bricht es auch weniger ab, wenn es von beiden Seiten gleich dran zieht.
Oh, oh, das sieht gut aus, das sieht gut aus, das sieht gut aus.
Ah, fast, das geht auf jeden Fall schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Oh, und ist es durch, nein, aber fast, aber fast, viel fehlt da nicht mehr.
Geh mit größerer Übersetzung, jawoll.
Success.
Bam.
So muss das sein, ein paar Gass.
Not broken, exquisite.
Ich glaub, das ist broken, das hätten wir auch ohne die krasse Vergrößerung erkannt.
Ich glaub, es ihm jetzt einfach war.
Ich mein, was geht mit den Leuten ab, bauen die jetzt alle Dinger, die irgendwelche Sachen
sonst... ne, das ist kein Logo, äh, kein Lego.
Richtig big brain time war das jetzt.
Leute, ich hab Hunger, ich geh jetzt, weil es erst noch aus dem Tube mit der Hals weh.
Können wir mal wieder Mario Kart spielen, ich hab nicht mal Mario Kart für die Switch.
Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen, bis denn, macht's gut, see you.